Mummy, the mummy hasn't abandoned no thing.
Mummy is in a foolish, foolish streamer.
When I did the footstream, I put my ring light,
I had to move my ring light so I could,
a little bit of shit and it would be done with the wall.
As it eliminate that mummy started streaming on her hands and knees,
it's not what she did.
Oh, I need the ring light.
The thing that's happening is the goofy and it's jumping about everywhere.
Everyone, hold on.
Oh, but it's going to be light.
Please, it's going to be light.
Okay.
Alright, my face is eliminated.
I'm also on reactive mode, so I'm actually going to react to the game.
Everyone knows I have an Nvidia GeForce RTX 3080,
with 10,067 megabits.
Hello, good morning.
Let me put on live chat, any live chatter.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
I apologize if I sound tired.
I passed out after that RuneScape stream,
and I woke up 45 minutes ago.
I hope Icy's monetization stream went fantastic.
I believe Emmys is also today,
so if there's any pin pals or snowberries,
they're down the hall.
Into the lift.
I apologize if I sound tired.
I am exhausted.
I don't know how.
I slept for so long.
I don't know what earth is going on with me.
But I've got cup of tea, I've got two waters,
I've got a wee muffin,
and then we can jump into Crash Bandicoot.
As for any updates, since I slept,
I have absolutely nothing.
A Riefling sent me a three page story,
which I really liked,
but for legal reasons,
I cannot speak any of it here.
I've also put together a little folder of Bibbius,
which I don't know why I didn't think to do earlier.
But now, now I'm putting it all together.
Oh, and a Riefling sent me a five minute audio.
And he was like, talk, yeah.
I was like, oh my God,
Rieflings are getting so brave, honestly.
And before I die a lot, probably,
probably, I'm not even going to put it behind me.
I don't know what level the desktop,
how loud the game's going to be compared to me,
but give me a three page story.
It was about me, obviously.
But yes, you guys have been doing fantastic.
I believe AC's doing well.
There's, I don't really have any updates
about anything else at the moment.
Other than my freaking ASMR meme video,
I've got 30 key views and I'm like, right,
this has definitely left the target audience,
because I had 5,000 subscribers when I posted that,
and now we're at 6,000.
I'm like, bro, that like propelled my channel.
So I'm waiting,
Mercy's is going to go up after the stream
or, or it's going to go up after
she finishes her stream today.
And then AC's is ready to go up.
I may, actually, I'm going to message her
right now so she can reply to me.
Now let's see, when you finished stream,
do you want me to upload your meme ASMR
on your behalf question mark?
And before you're like, wait,
why are you asking the girls permission
to do stuff that you made for them?
Because it's their channels.
I don't want them to be unhappy.
I want them to be happy little ducklings with me.
Who up?
Bandy their cooter.
Whoa.
Okay.
I'm getting a bit too close with that one.
Any Bandy girls.
It's running such a sweetheart.
Yes, I don't want to do anything that upsets the girls.
And if they're like, no,
now's not the time to upload the meme ASMR.
I won't upload the meme ASMR.
That's fine.
So I'll get permission from them
and then possibly after the stream.
Apparently it takes eight hours to do this game.
Now, I'm going to just say,
I was a atom when I played this game.
I have barely any recollection.
My dad didn't buy it for me.
He bought it for himself.
Johnny, congrats on 6.5K.
No, I also made ASMR videos.
I was going to try and get my first thank you video out.
Or maybe after a buckshot roulette after the doc.
Because I've got buckshot roulette.
Then I've got a couple of hours.
Then I go to the doctor.
Is this a rhythm game?
It is not.
It's Crash Bandicoot.
It is an adventure platformer.
I know you can't hear the background of the game right now.
So it's just my voice in this room.
Do forgive.
Johnny, when in a gang?
Any ganky desks?
Hold on.
Let me hydrate with my tea.
I owe so much ASMR.
I do have it all recorded.
I just need to sit and edit it.
And I can't upload the clapping without
using my hands ASMR.
Yet.
I need to have some things in between it.
Strongly winning much in everything, right?
It's a never-ending move.
Every time she releases an ASMR, she gains 1K
and she gets to go back to square one.
Honestly, I'm like, I hope not.
I think it will definitely calm down a bit.
It's going to have to calm down.
Because as much as our capitalist overlords
love infinite growth, that's just not plausible here.
Is it something that is healthy or thingy?
Because if you start measuring yourself by numbers
and that kind of thing, that's when...
I think that's when VTubers probably get it in their head.
They're like, oh, I'm not doing well enough.
I'm not performing well enough.
And it's like, brav.
You haven't even given yourself a chance.
Just have fun.
People can tell you're sweating on trends
if you're trying to sweat on trends, you know?
And then people can tell when you're just memeing around
or you're just memeing around, you know?
And guess what?
Some streamers...
Sorry, this is just turning into a philosophical...
Let's digest and get to the roots of why streamers are streamers.
Some people are just...
What's the word?
Optimised to have a nice, cosy, tight-knit community.
Some people, some of your personalities, other streamers,
you're just supposed to have a nice little tight-knit community.
You're not supposed to be for the masses, you know?
So don't always be reaching for the fricking stratosphere, the stars.
Don't always be reaching for the stars when you do just fine in the stratosphere, you know?
Every time you gain 1k, you release an ASMR that gains you 1k.
It's an infinite feedback loop you'll be at.
Infinity subs by the end of the week.
Not quite.
Especially those looking to extract numbers from TikTok
that only have 100 subs but say they deserve a million views on every post.
Yes.
I can actually get into the psychology on why people
feel they deserve subscribers
versus others who feel unworthy
of what they get because of what they've done.
I could definitely go on an algorithm stream that in...
Not tinfoil time!
No, it's not tinfoil! It's not tinfoil!
It's not tinfoil.
It's like actually, it's like human psychology
as well as the damage that the internet does to the mind.
Because if you didn't know, you're actually not supposed to be exposed to...
I think you're not supposed to actually know more than 100 faces at once.
And your brain is just not wired for any other way.
After that, your brain can only be wired to recognize tribes,
which sounds terrible, but that's just how it is.
So it's like, ah, I am approaching the AC clan, you know?
Or the tribe.
Are you studying psychology?
Absolutely not.
I have had enough of education.
I'm not...
I say that I might be going back to beauty school,
but that's for...
I'm talking like five years down the line beauty school type thing.
Because I might want to run an ASMR room studio type thing.
But that's just me.
That's just me.
Neither tinfoil hat or more.
Do the reeflings?
Honestly, I'm so down for that.
I need the meds to moat back.
I need the thigh gripper moat back.
All other emotes that I need back.
I was actually going to ask if a reefling has any batch to emotes,
wink, wink, if you could send me a cat box file of the batch itself.
So I know what to reorder.
Because I picked what I wanted.
Just so you know.
Just so we're all on the same...
I picked what I wanted.
Oh yeah, Crash Bandicoot 3.
Yes, so I was bought an atom and my dad bought this game for himself.
And the only thing I remember doing on this game is playing Coco on China
and using the horse all the time.
Eh, the horse?
The tiger all the time.
Eh, I'll have to catch stream later as I'm working on 80 slides of insurance termed out.
Ooh!
Even the thought of that is terrible.
I don't know what's going on with my tees.
I've not been enjoying them as of late.
I'm getting a bit...
I'm getting nervous.
I'm getting a bit shaky why I'm not enjoying my tees.
Because normally I'm all over them.
Although I have been enjoying this fruit juice company thing
and they put loads of fruit in the juice
and then they juice it
and then I drink the juice
and then I get all the goodness in me.
Yeah.
I've had too many teas.
This is a very plausible and realistic sense.
Although I've only had one tea the day.
I literally only...
I woke up like...
Well, I woke up an hour ago now.
I woke up, spammed the PC on,
started spamming pre-chat for a few moments,
checked out AC to see what's going on with her.
She's fine.
Checked out the Discord to see if the girls are fine.
They're fine.
Refillings lacking flavour lately.
You're not enjoying the tea because it's all just special, aren't you?
Oh my god.
It sounds terrible, but should I just get a cola?
I don't think drinking a cola first thing in the morning
is a good idea, though.
It's a terrible idea.
Okay, let's get into Crash Bandicoot.
Any Crash Bandicooters?
Is that too loud?
Or is that fine?
Oh my god.
How do I leave?
Oh, my controller isn't even awake.
Hold on.
Yeah, plug my controller in.
So there's three games in it.
I've only ever played Warped.
I don't know what the other two are about.
I guess the game.
Override save.
Is it too loud?
Guys, groovy as anything.
Maybe turn it down a little.
Okay, I'll do it in the start menu after the cutscene.
We're crashing?
I guess we are called Crash Bandicoot.
Thank you.
Free at last.
Oh my god, that's so beautiful.
Oh, it kind of looks like a snowberry.
Ooga, ooga is free.
No, it cannot be.
Evil, great evil has come.
Oh my god, this is so beautiful, this game.
Bandicoot.
Wait, it's a Tiki Mask, like Earth Tiki Mask.
I know we've had a few unfortunate setbacks.
Insane.
Oh, I don't remember any of this.
Fuck it.
That was a flashbang first thing in the morning.
Did you see that?
I can't see anymore.
Oh my god, this game is so beautiful and cool.
For real, I think I just got a virus.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, I remember something like that.
Oh my gosh, that was so beautiful.
Wait, hold on.
I need to turn down the volume a little bit.
My apologies.
Game option, music 8.
Wait.
I could do this all day.
We'll do 8s.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, you can't control the camera angle.
What does Y do?
Y shows me my light, what does B do?
No.
Oh my god, POV, I'm coming for AC.
I'm a Snow Berry going for AC.
Oh my god, on the prowl, on the prowl.
Oh my god, this is so precious.
This is so cool.
Oh my god, wait, I remember these symbols a little bit.
Oh look, I have a mask helping me too.
No.
I'll find out which one is more powerful.
Soon enough.
I mean, it's more powerful because I'm the goodie.
You're the baddie.
Oh my god.
Wait, where does this work?
Oh my god, this is like, you can.
Oh my god, we flints, we're already on the farm.
10 out of 10 game, we're already on the farm.
Right, how do I do that?
To jump, to spin, to crouch for inventory.
Why would I need to see my inventory?
I guess if you're going for like 100%, but...
Wee!
Oh my god, we can bomb.
This game is beautiful.
I remember that I don't need to hurt it.
Oh no, we spanked the goat.
Right, we spanked it.
We didn't kill it.
We spanked it away.
Okay, it's fine.
What's this?
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Thank you for the 5.
Okay, I can definitely take full damage.
Oh my...
Checkpoint!
I'm remembering.
Wait, go back on the farm.
What does this do?
Okay, if you hit it at a certain time.
Oh my god, we're on the farm.
Right, frogs.
Frogs can hurt us.
Go back on the farm, where you belong.
Go ahead.
Oh my god, I can spank everyone.
Oh, I love this game.
Wait, how about if I get 2 to go because...
Oh, he's glowing.
Oh, you are glowing.
What the heck is it?
What did I do?
Where am I going?
Oh no.
What's this?
Oh, it's bone.
I got an achievement for doing this.
It's a bonus level.
Wow, what?
Bum bum bum.
Is this just like free apples?
Oh my apples.
I never picked them up.
Oh my god, that's so cool.
Who found the dream?
The bleeding hearts are getting spanked.
For real.
A wimpa fruit.
One puff fruit.
Go back to the farm.
Oh, we trick shot with it.
The bleeding heart.
We trick shot it.
Go back to the farm.
No frog for Gen 2.
Uh...
Oh my god, Sheebie really wants a slim girl for Gen 2.
I don't know how to break it to her.
She really wants a Gen 2.
I'm just like, maybe I'll give Sheebie a Halloween outfit.
Wait, have we already been here before?
Or is this just kind of the same layout?
Okay, and it's spanked.
What?
Pink!
Why is there a gap in this bridge?
We need someone who works with stone to fix the bridge.
No slim girl?
No, maybe I'll give Sheebie a slim Halloween outfit.
How about that?
Slim girls.
I get the...
Oh, wait, so if you miss it, you'll...
Okay!
I missed a box!
Stinky, I don't know where it was.
Slim girls are my favorite monster girl.
Oh, but slimes are hot.
I'm not sure.
I don't know.
Oh, they came out of my earhole.
Oops.
And then we just go back in Ninja 2?
Oh my gosh, that's cool.
This game is easy.
I like how fun and easy it is.
Lamia is all my favorite.
I would entertain a Lamia.
Oh, the fisher thing.
To kick fast.
Whoa!
Whoa! Okay, wait, that was very dumb.
Sorry. That was incredibly dumb.
Whoa!
This game is so pretty.
Sorry.
I've not got much accuracy under the war,
even though I'm a cuttlefish.
I don't want to...
That just like will pass them.
Wait, that's a checkpoint.
Oh my gosh!
I remember something like this.
I used to be so scared of it as a child.
I thought I only remembered Coco.
Oh!
I can hear a box back there.
Wait, what does that shark do?
Please email him.
Oh, there's a sand dollar.
On the ground.
Wow, there's...
Jeez, this game is so cute.
I can't believe I didn't play this before.
Well, I mean...
Sorry, I got scared.
I don't know if I can hurt those pufferfish.
Checkpoint.
Why checkpoint?
What's here that shouldn't be here?
Is there something below that's going to kill me?
Because why did I get a checkpoint?
You can switch to play Coco!
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
What? I don't wonder this game did so good.
It's like so creative.
Oh, there is hidden boxes under the coral reef!
That's okay.
We're not going for 100%
because I don't know how to 100% this game.
But we can go for lots of fruit.
Okay, yummy yummy fruit.
Oh, I can beat shark up in this.
And I can explode things in this.
Let's go.
Oh no, I broke it.
I'm sorry.
I'm a bit of a klutz. I accidentally broke it.
Dun dun dun.
Oh wait, that's not the song anymore.
It's whatever the underwater.
Sure, we'll get these boxes.
I think it's safe for now.
Oh my god.
What do you mean I'm so in love with a game
that's got the difficulty for literal children?
I can't believe it.
The accusations are unfounded.
I play Skyrim on Legendary mode just because you can.
It doesn't mean you need to be...
Wait, can I hurt this?
Oh no, I can beat up the little puffer fish.
Oh, the purple puffers.
Okay, there we go.
Well, there's the prank crystal.
Okay, let's get it.
Wait, is that going to explode?
Oh wow!
If you don't do it in time, it becomes a solid.
Okay, that's curious.
Is it hard to get 100%?
Oh, I missed a lot of boxes this time.
Didn't do that good this time.
That's okay.
I'm happy just loving everything.
The scene remains me so much of Jack and Dax though.
Jack and Dax.
Oh, I threw that one up this time.
So it doesn't always come out your ear.
Wee!
The Orion Express.
Coco!
Oh, this is the mission!
Oh my god, this is the mission!
Ah!
Coco!
And what's the tiger's name?
Oh my god!
I know it's like first thing in the morning,
but I'm so happy!
Oh my god, this is the mission that I always
remember from childhood.
Oh my god, go Coco!
Go Coco!
You did it!
You're so beautiful!
Oh my god, it's the music!
Ah!
Get it, get it, get it, get it!
Oh my god, get it, get it, get it!
Yes!
Oh no, I hurt myself.
I didn't know what I was supposed to do there.
I forgot, but I got a checkpoint.
Oh, I jumped into it!
Coco, no!
Oh, but it's okay.
The tiger forgives me for being a terrible driver.
Oh, I did it again!
Oh shit, stop jumping!
Stop jumping!
Okay, no more jumping.
No jumpies, jumpies now.
But no jumpies.
And then big boy jumpies!
Oh, I missed!
What the heck, I was so close!
Oh, if I run ahead, I can attack.
Wee!
Rawr!
Tiger!
Ah, how can you...
Oh no!
It's so bad!
Oh my god!
Wait, what happens if I run out of lives?
Is it over?
Is it over for me?
This is over for Mesh.
Wait, can I just run ahead and hurt them?
Wee!
Rawr, there was a freaking leap in a half!
Call me Jewel Leeper,
because one tiger run is all it takes.
Wee!
Oh my god!
This is such a good machine!
Oh, my little tiger!
Soft kitty, warm kitty,
little ball of fluff.
Oh, that's the best mission
in the entire game.
Okay, we can end stream them.
That's all we needed to do.
Wee!
Oh!
I don't know what the diamond is.
Right, what we got next?
The Boneyard!
There are like three more of that?
Oh my god!
What?
Oh no!
Neurons activated from childhood.
I think I get chased
this entire mission!
Oh no!
There's lava everywhere!
It's jumping faster!
Oh, I don't know, I'm jumping faster!
Oh my god!
Why did you do that? Crash!
Crash, why did you do that?
Crash, jump! Crash!
Crash, you need to jump!
Like, double jump!
Whoa, wait, I can't do it!
Wait, can I just stay here forever
in the tower?
Is that a Tyrannosaurus talk or something like that?
Wait, why can I not jump that?
Can you double jump it again?
Is it...
Oh, is it that? Jump, spin?
Whoa, I could hardly get over that!
Oh no!
I can't believe it, childhood
me strikes again.
Can I not double jump?
Hold the jump!
Hold the jump?
What the heck? I'm not going to make it!
I'm going to run out of lava!
Oh no!
Wait!
Wait, it's not doing anything!
Hold on, let's practice.
Jump, jump, jump, jump!
Jump, uh!
Uh, uh, uh!
Ah!
I don't know how to double jump!
Uh, uh, uh!
It's not letting me double jump!
Oh, it is letting me double jump!
Wait, but I jumped right into it!
Oh my god!
It's so over and the stream
hasn't even freaking started!
I can't figure it double jump!
Is my input wrong?
I'm holding A on my controller.
There is no double jump.
Uh, uh!
I'm getting so confused.
Is this a child's game or not?
Answer me!
Is this game for kids to complete or not?
It's not looking good.
Can't even get through the first freaking jump!
Woo!
Hey!
Dash jump is one way.
Is for kids.
I'm getting filtered by level 3.
I actually am!
I don't know how to go through this.
Level 3, I actually am!
I don't know how to do it!
I'm, like, trying to extend the jump.
But there's nothing to extend it.
It's just a straight magma jump!
Woo!
You unlock double jump after beating a boss.
Wait, so leave and then go to see a boss
and come back?
Are you holding your jump button
down instead of tapping?
If I tap, hold,
tap.
Holding, tapping.
Right, hold A.
Holding A!
Fuck!
This is me holding A!
Okay.
It just seems to be, like, so tiny and
slate.
Like, minuscule.
Woo!
Right, this is the furthest I've ever got.
Don't mess up now.
Okay.
I need a breather, honestly.
Right, I'm just going to keep going.
Oh my god!
Why is that so hard?
Oh, that's TNT!
Wee!
That's more TNT!
They explode!
Okay, we did it.
Oh, gee willikers, I sure hope we don't have to do
that segment again, because, uh,
what the heck? Why is that so hard?
I literally have no double jump open.
You should try jumping over them.
Taming matters.
What's this?
Oh, a platform?
I don't have access to it.
Golly, you scared me.
Oh my god, it's discord nature!
Is this...
What does that do?
Okay, well,
I remember what it does now.
Wait, can I do this?
Oh.
Go away, you're so creepy!
What are you?
Oh, bonus time, bonus time!
That's what it does.
Yeah.
Don't touch the nature.
No discord daddies.
Or no discord groomers in the velar.
Good luck.
Wow.
Bence?
Bounce?
Oh my god, I get free life.
Well, I definitely needed that after how...
Oh!
He just scooted.
Why is he so slow when he crouches though?
Okay, I like the bonus distance.
Where's the key?
Try to tap crouch
when walking to get faster.
Tap crouch while walking.
Oh, every hundred apples,
I get a life.
Ah, those things are so scary.
For a duke.
Exclamation mark.
What the heck did I just do?
Oh no, I was supposed to jump.
I missed the jump.
Oopsies, I was supposed to jump on top of them.
Oh good.
I don't like this camera angle.
No, this is why I didn't like the camera angle.
It felt like I was going to get chased again.
Okay, give me the checkpoint at least.
Oh, there's...
Gate the way up.
Oh no!
What was that?
Crash?
Did you just stand on lava and let me win?
Oh my god, the game feels so bad for me.
That is letting me win.
It feels so bad for me.
Please don't slow me down.
Oh my god, get me out of here.
Oh, get me out of here.
I'm not playing this level again.
Wampa Fruits, they're wampas.
Oh my god, the game felt so bad
it let me walk on lava.
Oh, that came up more.
Honestly, me right now.
Did I do four there?
Yes, I did. Right, we're not playing that one again.
That one was stinky. We're doing five.
We're doing...
Oh, Coco!
What's this one?
It's me.
Eh?
To accelerate, right trigger.
There's no backwards.
Oh my god, it's so wobbly, wobbly.
Whee!
Jump shot.
Wah!
Yoo-hoo!
Oh my god, this is...
Oh, there's a bomba.
Wait, wait, let me get the bomb.
Oh, 360.
That's okay. 360!
She's actually doing spins.
I'm not doing any input for her
to do those spins, by the way.
I'm just jumping on it.
Oh, there's bombas!
Bomba!
Oh no, I've only got seven lives.
Oh well, I just regained a new one.
Okay.
This is a child's game. Children can play this.
So I can play this.
I'm wise enough to play a child's game.
Surely.
Surely I won't have to run out of lives.
If I play at the same level
over and over,
Dad just gets infinite lives.
Because we might have to farm lives
unironically.
Right, hold on. What's going on here?
No. Yes.
Yes. Okay, we made it and we're going to get this checkpoint.
Wah!
Eh, excuse me.
I said we're going to get this checkpoint.
Oh my god.
It's edging me right now.
Wah!
Oh, that was close. That was close.
I was a bit too close for comfort.
Uh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Timon's going to be fine. It's fine.
Oh, there's a seagull!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Slow it down. Slow it down.
Slow and steady.
When's the race?
Then you need to go 100 miles per minute.
Wah!
Honestly.
Good game.
I am going to drop into the bomb.
But I didn't because I'm so
emotional at this child's game.
Wah!
Oh, there's two bombs. That's cheeky.
The devs did that for a reason.
They knew I was going to be greedy
and go for the bomba.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hello?
Okay. Holy crap.
I was like, can I even go near that
wall?
Steady, easy, easy.
Take it easy.
Steady.
I'd say someone steady when's the race.
But sometimes, sometimes you got to
just send it and get out of here.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is so good.
Who suggested this game?
Congrats on you if you suggested it.
Just kidding. I picked it
because it's a childhood game.
Okay.
The boss fight.
Oh, no.
Tiny Tiger.
I'm not going to get perished by a boss.
Crash.
Sometimes he has...
Oh, no.
Oh, the music is banging, though.
Oh!
Oh, no.
MonkaS?
MonkaS? What'd I do?
MonkaS, MonkaS, MonkaS, MonkaS.
Ah!
Please leave me alone.
Oh my god, he's got J's on like me.
Spank.
Okay. It's fine.
One and three.
What does that mean?
There's Tigers!
I'm to avoid...
everything?
What?
I'm to avoid all those Tigers?
Spank
And then Tigers, right? We can do this.
We can do this.
Okay. Take your time.
Uh-huh.
Oh, yeah. Uh-huh.
Uh-huh. Oh, yeah.
Okay. Okay. I just got a little caught up in this.
The last one.
Okay. Just keep running.
Just keep running. Just keep running.
Just keep running. Spank!
And then we do it all over again.
Okay.
Okay. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
Let's go. This is so much faster
than the second phase.
But that's okay!
Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Just keep running.
Just keep running around.
He'll come to me.
We did it. We're doing it. We're doing it.
We're doing it. We're doing it.
Spank! Oh, we did it!
What did we get?
What is this?
Boo! Tomato! Tomato!
Boo!
Beat him while he's down! Beat him while he's down!
Argh!
Take this.
Okay. What is this?
Supercharged body slam
for a more professional belly flop.
Press A and B
to the top of the jump.
Please! I love this so much!
Oh, that's so good.
I love it.
Momay domination.
Dang straight.
Dang straight!
Well done, children.
By defeating Tiny,
you have unlocked the gate to the next time travel area.
Go back to the center of this time, Trister,
and save your progress if you wish.
From there, you will see
that the gate to the second time travel area
is now open.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay.
Okay, so I've unlocked everything in this one.
In the castle segment.
How do I save the game?
Left trigger, save.
Uh, sure.
Oh, auto-save is already active.
That's fine.
Yeah, just save that though.
Yeah, okay.
Just in case.
What is this?
So we've got Arabia,
China,
Egypt,
the future,
South Korea then,
for the future.
Are you squidding me right now?
Tiny, Spiny!
I would just like to formally say that I,
Tiny, Spiny, am not associated with
Tiny, Tiny in any way,
and do not endorse his actions.
No.
Way to go with the game so far.
It's going so good.
I love it.
Thank you for the five gifted memberships.
Congrats to those who caught it with your face.
It means you get access to the moots.
I'm going to very quickly grab a can of cola.
I'll be literally in those seconds
because I couldn't finish my tea,
so I'll just get cola.
Surely we can't be no weak to me at all.
Sure.
My question,
briefly,
is surely not all commissions are that short
because there's only five locations.
And if there's only five locations,
I don't...
I think they were going to be finished with Game in two hours
and redirect him into Sheevie
because there's no way.
Thank you for the gifted membership
for Jinger, and thank you for
the tip, Tiny, Spiny,
if.
They're short, but you'll die a lot.
What happens if I get zero lives?
Like, I genuinely lose?
This is called
G-Wiz
and...
It deletes your save file?
Am I being trolled right now?
Or did I genuinely lose all progress?
Because this is an old game
and that's exactly what old games did.
They make you lose your...
Whoa.
Go back to the farm!
Back to the farm!
Oh!
Barely float!
Ah!
Okay.
Oh!
Ah!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
The way I absolutely
decimated that poor man.
It's not that old.
You just lose your score and start from your latest level.
Oh!
A game over. The player is given the option to either restart the game
from the beginning of the level.
kind of with the standard number of lives for or to quit to the title screen okay so I don't lose
all my progress that's good because if I lost all my progress we're actually going to play a game
called conquers bad fur day but conquers bad fur day is so old that you oh my god I like got a
trick shot there and it's so old that you lose your progress if you mess up and so I'm gonna try
and win conquers bad fur day but I actually have terrible news I don't know if I can win it go back
on the farm both of you you've been getting so distracted playing boy ah not me I don't like
me just boy check in go checkpoint oh this game is so good doesn't mean how do you not blow up that
nature as if it's not right next to you oh my god crash
oh my shoes no I got too excited I need to unlock double jump like right now I'm so bad
literally has like infinite health enemies can't touch me and what defeats me a gap in the ground
like okay I see how it is
bleeding the heart was coming right at me oh no not me oh I don't like me just
big jump great checkpoint is there gonna be like an enemy behind this I feel like this is too
no there isn't okay I'm surprised wow oh I miss well you know bonus time bonus time oh that frog
just did itself in I don't know if you saw that he's that I've had enough only strong
crash and conquer both her girls that make you go I'm not a furry but
actually crash and conquer both ginger what are the odds of that thank you don't miss for the tip
I appreciate it yeah conquerors bad Friday I don't I have no idea why my dad let me play that game
know that I think about it because it's absolutely outrageous oh wait I can't really
oh my god I like the jumpy ones uh yeah conquerors bad Friday was far too inappropriate
oh it's a timer it's a timer it's a timer oh oh oh it's a timer oh give me all for it I don't
like tamer stuff sorry oh wait no I missed the box back there let me go down go down I missed the
box I missed the box let me go back I missed that
oh oh well farm no
oh they're in oh there's two of them no farm
to the farm you will be a slave on it and you will do all the bidding and then the
reeflings can have a day off because you're the bad guy farm no
no it was on the bonus level I'm a stinky stinkerton I asked the game to put me go back but never
took me back I'm eating my blueberry muffin because I need to eat
what's in the box disappointment because I can't go back I want to go back I want to go back okay let
me eat my muffin classic 5am physios honestly oh my god this this ost is banging I didn't
realize how good crash bandicoot was like for the ost I didn't remember any of it but
I'm
have you talked to coco in the hub um I don't really search for that stuff when I'm on the
hub I'm more of a overwatch search that's terrible interact ray bumper hi do you want her to join
your adventure I can go be coco oh that's gonna confuse me sorry coco you're gonna have to go
away oh wait I get to play as a girl oh a girl gamer
she's just like me for wait hold on I'm gonna be coco because I'm a girl
all right let me finish my muffin it's like a little baby blueberry muffin
oh
I cannot wait to get 3d models because you will see how much I move around and like articulate
with my hands and all of that boy thank you for the gifted member and ebos thank you for
becoming on the membership tier membership streams start next week so after buckshot
roulette or probably at the start of buckshot roulette stream I will reveal to you my humble
schedule for a stream that week oh yeah you successfully avoided the membership again
can't wait for strongy flip is off in 3d bro I saw someone 3d model have physics around their
buttocks area and I'm like I need that ASAP
sorry I've almost finished my muffin
oh my god these games have such charm like when your characters afk they do like a little idle
thing like it's oh oh we've got a phone call hold on who's this AC what's going on
hmm all right bye she hardly even spoke to him right are we on seven hang them high
literally there's like so much detail whoa what's this oh my god
who knows Aladdin soundtrack Prince Ali may is he Ali I'll whoa what am I supposed to do with
that I must have spank him when he looks away yeah that's what you get thank you again boy boy for
the five gifted member big congrats to those who caught it whoa what's that oh what is that well
the fuck is that what the fuck what does he do does he just block the way okay oh my god
I'm sorry but that's so menacing when something follows your movement pattern that is so menacing
I did not enjoy that don't do that again don't ever spawn in an enemy like that again because it's
so like scary hold on I'm having a cola hydration check
wow no no Coco stop getting phone calls god you're one busy girl what's this oh wait hold on
wait jump and then hit yeah and then
wow oh my god I feel like games like this was used to be so creative honestly right jump down
checkpoint what was it oh dab oh that was so mean he had to delivery to do and I just ruined
his delivery gooey you scare me menacing man on a carpet wow oh my god there's so much whoa
oh there's a monkey again that's okay there's a mark oh I hurt myself but when you hurt yourself
you also hurt the enemy okay okay I'm learning I'm learning I'm learning wow I can't see checkpoint
I can't see no I am a monkey oh wait I didn't realize I could do that oops
and go away go away man on the carpet go away you scare me
I don't really want scorpions on the fans so I don't think we'll send them oh there's
a bonus level down here look I see it I see it I see it take us to the bonus level
you miss some boxes I know I didn't realize I could attack whilst I was hanging out
oh I missed completely oh no I got you baited I'm supposed to go up here oh no
wait I'd rather go for a life oh I was speeding up oh wait I can't get them whoa that was lucky
wait what
how am I supposed to get that one down there
butt bouncing adventures pre-dlc how am I supposed to get down there was that supposed to do something
I don't know chief I didn't get it TNT I'm supposed to blow it up oh
let's just be doing butt bones and adventures for Elden Ring even though
so for the Elden Ring DLC wow
those are so good oh we're at 14 lives as well that's fantastic I can't wait to make 14 mistakes
oh he bumped me away
check boy
what am I supposed to do here that oh I couldn't get over it
see you lanky tall bastards honestly how'd I do the bottom one
right right right right right how'd I do the bottom ones okay that makes sense
oh you know what you know what give me double jump already just give me double jump this is
getting outrageous just give me double jump right you look ready perish to the fires of gondor
wait no that's not cast it into the fires of gondor no that's not right
he was pushed me off the map don't bump me what does that do oh go away wait what does that do
well something just happened I don't know what
well get me out of this level so as I got too confused I'm not well enough for that
the fires of gondor I don't know why I said that look I'm trying I'm doing too many things at once
okay this is really hard on my brain I didn't like that one that mission was scary the we
the we uh hog ride how creative I'm sore but how oh my god it really said no women are allowed
to drive wow this game did not age well that's terrible I shouldn't have said that oh wait what
okay great am I just to get through the level without getting hurt I think I can do that
oopsies oh no the pole it's a polis lads it's a polis pause right who's got a bag on them
I don't want to touch them right we're doing a jump kick
oh wait I'm fourth place I'm to beat these people oh oh no oh no this can't be I didn't
realize I was actually racing I was just having fun driving to be honest I just think this is a
cool map oh no I'm supposed to win okay hold on oh no I lost no wait accelerate oh no wait why did
I just pull I just break through to let that guy go third wait I won though
oh no I didn't win oh no I have to actually win I was just having fun driving not gonna lie I was
like oh this is actually a really fun wee game oops is there like a boost button or is it literally
just send it okay I'm just going for it uh I don't know if there's a sender I think I maybe
have to hit all the green boosts and it like guarantees you to go ahead of whoa crash what are
you doing the steering crash oh my god there is like no steering oh wait I don't die if I hit them
okay right I'm third place I just need to hit all the green that comes up
uh right all right hold on I'm looking for the green to get me ahead crash please stop skittin
skittin a boot okay there's a green there oh get in my way your ball back no no
right again again again again he was in my way he was in my way right try again go again crash
try again he was in my way on the greenery the green pads are the boost yeah
right let's freaking try that again
I feel like when I played this as a child if I even got this far I probably would be crying right
now you know how like kids cry in frustration when they can't win I feel like I'd be greeting right
now because I'm so bad at the game would you laugh at a young strongy crying right now crying
are we eyes out right I'm third place there should be like three green speed ups ahead I'm not going
to break the boxes I'm wondering if that slows me down a bit but I'll go ahead so that's me second
please okay crash you're gonna have to put crash no wait what am I supposed to do it's
by a ball here it's by a ball here ladies and gentlemen I go first place oh my god we did it
we did it we are the champions there's no time for this because we are the champions
of the world it's Tim Tang forget Tim reader
oh no not the Aussies anything but the Australians no save us oh are you squidding me right now
Jack thank you for the tip well done well done strongy purple burglar I don't know maybe not
the farm maybe go with the animal sanctuary rescue thank you for the two Jack oh my god we're in
turncammons too oh this is oh look at the detail on the walls I'm sorry but they didn't they don't
they don't make games like they used to look at wow what is that a croc a donkey right go wait
it got my butthole I didn't freaking I didn't even get a checkpoint that's how not far into the
game I was they got my freaking butthole I'm so bad great big jump and then up the stairs
and then jump okay that's fine that thing that was just bad timing whoa whoa it's oil
I'm really scared oh my god it's made from overwatch I can't believe the basis game on
whoa okay oh my god she's so cute when she skates I love coco boom boom boom oh look at the detail in
the boat uh yeah I saw that I saw that I had video game knowledge to know something was it right
there Brian oh Brian but no message thank you for the tip Brian but no message Brian
don't tell America there's oil there we get invaded wait there's TNT everywhere oh this is not
gonna go well for me get me the heck out of here I'm not even just ah
okay just blows up TNT in the vicinity okay that's fine oh no I'm scared I'm hiding
something just went flying I don't know what but thank you for the tip Brian
okay yeah I knew there was something up there but I didn't want to jump on it because I got scared
oh wait I could have barely flopped on the other side of the map oops I can't believe it I'm not an
MLG gamer what's this oh it's a time oh my god it's the anchor symbol is that a gen 2 reference
oh
I need to jump over this okay I can do that see you yo bam great oh wait oh no oh I got uh
I heard that what did you hear what is this am I am I a vampire are you squid in here
creative games are still around they just rarely see the light of day against the
place that spend more on marketing than development but jingle thank you for the five
you know what I actually was intrigued I can't do it this month or maybe next month I don't think
I have enough time however I am so down to do like um what I am so down to do like showing off
game dev type how the heck did I get over there I cannot make that jump I know that perfect I'm
like so down to do that to like give game devs that are like smaller uh a bigger chance type thing
and we write like a little review oh we write a little review at the end oh no oh no this can't be
look all the paint like look at the detail they're implying that they're painting the murals right
no like look it's so fun it's cute thank you again for the five by Jinka how do I do this
is it a timer I don't know okay it's a timer do not be distracted from the fact that it's a timer
as beautiful as the game's uh the game's uh background and storytelling is the thingy
it is a timer so do not be fooled wait until it gets close to you okay wait until it gets close to
you oh right hold on hold on hold on child's game absolutely decimating me oh my god grown
grown women beaten to pulp via child's game right once it opens then just go straight for it right
I'll wait until that comes back because yeah unless Coco can just stand on this okay yeah
okay we're safe we're safe right wait how am I supposed to get around that
oh wait no there's a life back there okay that's what I need yes
that sounded terrible I said I need a lifter
right we've got a checkpoint right go
uh huh oh no Coco Coco right no wonder there's a freaking checkpoint there Coco what was that a
bismill attempt you know exactly what you were doing hands you perish and whoa
flamethrower is a bit dramatic this is a child's game
I'm scared oh I'm scared oh get me off this level I hate platforming like that oh get me off get me
off get me off off end of the portal we go safety safety
only time strongy gets my uh reflins are you not coming to the convention hold on a minute
hold on this is news to me we're not we're not going to the convention right no I played that one
and I just did that one didn't I okay so we're gonna play midnight run okay midnight run
what's my tiger called I'm sure my tiger has a name oh my god he's so cute I can't handle it tiger
confirmed for Jin too oh my god you're so cute oh my god jump jump high oh there's a lot of enemies
up here
oh jump oh check mark
uh jump jump food
oh I love this freaking tiger so much oh my god why am I doing so much better on later
levels than I'm on the early level oh my god you're cheesy doodle did you see that oh my god I
chase you down on uh uh uh uh right checkpoint checkpoint jump
I saw that I saw what the game was trying to do I'm like I'm tryharding on this level I don't
care I love it and I love love me tiger love me Coco love me China wall simple oh my god this
freaking best level ever I know jump jump slid slid I love the tiger Jin one year one for now
it's 100k what steady on steady on uh no I think I'll hold it for a while
shouldn't it be gaming like a pro I freaking love oh no we're doing a boss fight right
cola check everyone hydrate we're about to do a boss fight
the tiger's called Pura oh my god Jin to confirm tiger girl called Pura I'm not
even care oh I've just tabbed out that was a terrible idea sorry I just tabbed out of the game
I got I got a dm uh okay I have I have good news for everyone I don't I have good news for everyone
mercy and aces meme ASMR are going up today I just got confirmation from the squadron
dingodale a dingodale a dingodale oh my god that's such an Aussie name
oh my god they said no whammin fights yay tiger girl called Pura Pura Pura Pura Pura Pura Pura
in crystals are mine
call me Pura
uh uh what what is this
um
I don't I don't understand how he all locked me oh I did it again wait wait wait wait hold on
sorry sorry I'm looking I'm looking where his gun is pointing sorry give me give me a second
that takes me a second to figure things out for myself hold on hold on my brain isn't hot
wires like the way it's hot wired for you right he's aiming there ah he keeps aiming
now what oh he keeps going oh please don't do that oh please don't do that I'm trying to hurt him
okay oh
okay I just need to do that three times okay okay I just needed a second to digest what
the game is asking me to do that call I just needed a cheeky second right if he just keeps
all locking I could probably just keep going like this oh no okay okay okay we're doing it we're
doing it we're doing it we're doing it okay okay okay last one boys I just need to look on the ground
no oh no does he do variation attack oh okay nice and easy
wow we did it we did it we did it unless we need to do anything special I think that's good
oh my god he let you win with a hegeo at the end
yeah get him penguin beat his ass penguin we'll do it together no one will do it yeah beat him up
beat him up we love penguins in me gen 2 penguin confirmed double jump yes a jump twice as high okay
I can probably replay those other missions if I so desired no oh my god look at that vertical leap
look at that vertical leap oh wow get me in the m m mba's right now mba's
nba nba get me in the mba's right now coco show us that double jump wow look at that
she's a cheerleader oh my god she's such a cheerleader right we're going to turn the turn
let's go right what we eating first ah back to some dimsums we're doing the dano mate
oh my god that's such a good name for a tnt dinosaur oh my god gen 2 confirmed sorry I'm
just stealing all my gen 2 ideas from crash bandicate I don't mind if I do well haven't we got
for a pair of paze marsupials I am dr nefarious tropey master of time and the creator of the
very time twister machine you see the foil uka uka and dr cortex have sent me to end
this little shroud so you won't be leaving my area with the crystals I swear
wow this game is so fun thank you for no no no is that what I think it is
is this going to be a chase sequence
I take it all back oh is this a chase sequence oh my god I can like clear those with east
what the heck is that honestly honestly oh that's lava that's not a path oh my goodness my brain
literally registered that last second oh my god this looks like a chase sequence map
so I will not go turn the lights off carry me home oh my god that fish is so freaky it's supposed
to look like crash in that I'm not just making that up oh go away oh go away you're so creepy
I'm scared I don't like it wait why are you not possible that's the second one that's not possible
I wonder why that's not possible why the grass slowed me down
no oh I stood on its head oh it's like Mario if you stand on its head it's gone it's deep if you stand
on it wait what does that egg do hello we kiss the egg and let it germinate
am I supposed to break it I really don't want to break it I feel like that's really
I don't want to break the egg I'm sorry there's something germinating inside it we want it to
wish it success great success in your in your life
break the egg I don't want that there's something living inside it if you although saying that you
can actually grow chickens without their shell or being cracked open and I don't actually recommend
you doing it but what did you see that how big that thing was going
no egg we are nice to nature
oh okay okay
music is so good
I love children's games I love them being relatively easy
yeah that's right I smarted that segment and you're exactly
bonus mission you gotta break it break egg help it hatch oh I'm to help it hatch oh that's
different then okay I'll break the eggs when I see them
butt smash oh I missed that one back there that's okay butt smash
oh that's like so many wumpa fruit
what and the life which I definitely need how much I can't read
I couldn't reach it anyway oh well
uh oh well we let's go
what's running are we weave you don't get excited no I saw it did you see it too
I saw the tyrannosaurus ring
I have double jump okay okay trust in the double jump okay wow you're going so fast
I have double jump and I still feel that jump wow
ah
oh Coco this camera angle isn't helping darling Coco yes a bear camera angle please
oh please give us a bear camera angle oh get me out of here oh my god
how are you supposed to know what's coming up
how are you supposed to know no more dino missions please my heart can't take it I'm
getting so stressed out deep trouble okay my time
we we still call that a skill issue okay okay you're done back to the yeah yeah you need reaction
time I don't have reaction time though what can I go up no sorry the game almost looked like I could go up
okay let's hope I don't mess this up uh too much I'm just gonna spam
oh my god yes spamming whoa why did you not get hit oh well I'll leave you alive
but tell your family ah I almost got LA
oh my god gentle actually that's I'm so sorry if you get sick of that meme
it's probably the funniest like the thing I enjoy right now
is just full going oh my god gentle this character confirmed I don't know I just find it really funny
okay I can beat up sharks under water thank you
uh I'm stuck in a vortex
okay it's fine we made it we made it
wow
I like the tissues are just hanging out in this one winter thing just
oh god that was two for one
oh oh my god crash bandicoot really said inflation inflation confirmed for gentle
I'm so sorry okay oh I did it twice oh my god I'm so sorry please excuse me by all means
right let's not do that again spin right there geez why was that so hard
I don't know what the purple crystal does but does it like a lock a bonus thing for me later maybe
I'm just using my damage to get out
whoa I didn't even see that okay literally spinning damage helps you move so much faster
inflation bow
oh
oh I broke my my boat no my boat I'll fake it whoa oh I don't have a mask right now so this is
extra scary right
eh I didn't know you died in the vortex oh no how far back am I I lost me boat are we
better go I'm just spamming wait am I going crazy no oh my god we're going to the rapture
bio shock confirmed oh wait I can just destroy the natural boxes when I'm like this that's fine
oh no why am I so bad at timing okay I made it I made it I made it oh right okay I literally
perished right before the end of that level you need the purple crystals to unlock the boss
oh okay bow shock Jen I know literally I'm sorry it's my favorite joke right now because I have
had messages like that that have been like you said this in one stream does that mean is this the
oh my god wait can the girl drive girl can't drive wow wow you mean a big sister
oh we don't have a big sister do we we do have a mama and see what I do
maybe we should do like a a cousin third removed for Jen too oh no I'm terrible at the different
people oh no okay let's get to it everybody let's get to it to it let's get them parties popping
right wait they can use the ramps I thought they can use the ramps I thought only I could
that's how I was like predicting where they were gonna go go away no
get out my way
this is my road so it is
oh my god sorry it's like wait what are you even with the controls are I'm sliding if I do a
I'm definitely lost this one that's all I'm gonna say we're gonna play we are replaying this
for as long I don't know what the controls are can someone tell me what the controls are because
I'm I'm holding like oh I'm a but I'm like I'm well no I'm holding right trigger but
he's making me slide everywhere and that just instantly stopped my speech is
what is going on I'm confusion
I'm I'm a philosopher because I'm Confucius what the heck
bro stop sliding crash crash what is going on yeah I've definitely haven't won this one
get it my way I'll rearrange you and make it look like an accident wait I don't know what
sorry I'm gonna have to look up the controls for this game mode because I'm definitely doing
something wrong like crash speeds up and then he slows down wait I'm no see like I don't have
any turn in power when he does that get crash crash orange crash our insurance bill is gonna be oh wait
whoa they really said Mario Kart out here didn't they they said if you fall off the map it's fine
controls just accelerate I just accelerated and got sixth place so
something tells me I'm doing something wrong
strongly confirmed for gen 2 I need first progress to the next mission guys I have a terrible
feeling we're gonna be here I just got ran over did you see that insurance fraud simulator on a
just got ran over oh my god child's game it's okay your sixth place but we still love you
literally bring is it is there accelerate just before a green light to boost one to boost
that okay hold on a minute we're getting the strats I managed to read the help screen
okay okay let him get up let him get up get out my way right everyone's doing that but I actually
don't know if you're slower on ramps or not right okay hold up hold up hold up hold up we're getting
there we're getting there if he if you cross the road right now you're such a vampire you're
actually such a freaking idiot he purpose that can I reset because there's no way I'm gonna win
resume oh you can't reset he's such a liar literally swerving into me I'm faster I'm I really
don't feel it why are all these cops cops on the route I know literally meter springs out here
with a cop hiding behind the billboard to catch lightning McQueen what's that I know the lore of
freaking cars yeah what are you gonna do about it
wait oh my god car girl confirmed for gen 2 but you get to stick it in her exhaust pipe
oh my god did you guys see that thing on youtube where the guy's in love with his car it was like
my weird obsession and he makes love to his car and it's red I just remember the car being red and
me being like huh huh okay we're actually somehow doing better even though I've played
considerably worse yeah like he keeps going off the map I don't know why
the a okay well I'm still uh excuse me insurance fraud people on the phone right now
oh my god why did they make this so hard
I just got ran over again um right hold on let me look up the controls because I don't think
anyone I said two things to me when I played the game mode for the first time hold on crash
bandicoot warped um what is this motorcycle controls xbox I'll put xbox because I'm using xbox
controller hold down the x button to accelerate and square to break I said xbox controls we don't
have a square so it's literally breaking go
it's literally just breaking go and that's it what is it so
to is a accelerate
I guess a is accelerate right and then I just need to focus on not oh my
oh and you don't we don't even have an option to reset I don't know if I'd be faster to reset
and then go again brah literally get out my way honestly can the game tell that I'm
a struggling child and then the AI will lower you know how some of those games have like reflective
and they're like oh my god you're struggling we're just gonna lower the game
difficulty for you can I have that please I'm literally struggling so hard
right stop drifting crash it's it's causing a lot of issues it's causing a lot of issues
I'm not even gonna pretend otherwise can you stop oh right right right right right right right
right I get it I get it crash crash oh oh I'm actually gonna have a word with you once the stream
is over oh my god can I really not progress wait I'm gonna back out and see if I can just skip to
the next level because oh my yeah and there's so many police on the road and they're not even
doing their job you're not even a civil servant you're not even serving the public at all just
hanging about on route 66 for any reason honestly they wonder like folk call themselves a sovereign
citizen you're doing shit no again please oh my god
please okay I'm gonna back out and I'm gonna see if we can progress to the next
thing because this is impossible they wonder Coco's right no don't restart level give me a
break let me come back to it let me come back to it because I don't know what I'm supposed to do
I don't know how I'm supposed to do it right we're not doing road crash more like right
hang time so what did I just do 12 no what
okay we're doing 15
oh wow it does let you skip ahead thank god thank god you need that crystal no
no
okay you can't even do anything against those guys at all
oh
I didn't want to break it but hey oh oh you don't get anything out of them
right I can definitely do this
what who put all this poison to turn the freaking frog there's wait how am I supposed to get past
oh my gosh that was like so close I'm sorry but I don't I don't know what the hitbox is like in
this game but I'm feeling it Mr. Krabs oh okay I was just gonna belly flop
well that wasn't worth it
swing swing and then get past okay we're doing it we're doing it it's fine it's fine
so if I do this no let's not
I don't really want to set it all
I thought I had enough distance to do that okay I won't do that again I'll leave the TNT as is
I don't need anything from the TNT
two one jump
whoa I almost perished right we're leaving TNT alone because I don't know how to deal with it
I ain't smart enough for this
we bouncy bouncy don't
right I don't need that I don't really know what to do with it either but I don't need it
go to the farm right now
no there's a mage
farm farm we need lots of folks so they can um help with the pests in the garden
okay we can do special mission
her disdain for mages it's because they have an auto lock
and I don't like auto locking
it just so you know AC is live with uh watch along all that the movie that you guys are
all featured in you guys didn't tell me that you were in a movie oh no this can't be
how are you supposed to get back
yeah how are you supposed to do that I don't know um someone said there's no sheepster stream um
there's no sheepster stream today
I don't know what the plan is for Azura oh I've got another life I've got 18
literally me yeah she's doing the karaoke now okay is there is there AC's doing karaoke
Emmy I believe is also doing her feet today any any 10 toenail enjoyers please feel free to
enjoy Emmy's 10 toenail
ripping piss my toenail uh I don't know someone said it may grow back I mean it could
oh yeah let's see to the farm
okay wow no no no no no I hate all attacks
oh wait oh that's a lot of well I'm okay wow wait
can I not I thought I couldn't hurt these guys
okay I can just bump over them I guess
is that no that doesn't perish all the enemies I thought I don't know what that is
Emmy streams too late for me hope for a void
long as she doesn't go out of control wait so
I can't progress oh no I can't progress until I do the driving mission
look reefland I'm gonna be honest I think we're in here for the long haul
oh this isn't gonna go well reeflings
yeah this is gonna turn into an endurance stream at this rate
okay okay on the green one two now we've got a boost good to go get out my way
and then just take it easy as long as crash doesn't start like violently sliding on the tracks
it's yeah see when you do that crash when you do that crash it becomes very hard to control
what I'm trying to do so don't do that again crash and maybe just maybe
yeah okay that's fine haven't really done anything that's messed us up too dramatically
we can share we can share the ramp that's fine we can share the ramp right crash
all this sliding crash is exactly what I'm talking about stop sliding right now
stop it stop it young man okay okay don't freaking don't freaking do anything different
because I'm third place in crash bandicoot crash oh my god I'm so sorry if anyone's name is crash
right now your like heart rate must be accelerating I'm second please I'm second place I'm second please
I'm second place I'm second please I'm second please I'm second please I'm second please I'm second
please crash crash crash oh oh oh I can see it I can see it stop sliding please
stop stop oh my god I think we did it crash I am going to lose it I am going
to lose it oh my god we did it oh we can do the boss thanks god oh my god
right holy crap I'm so sorry if anyone's name is crash you're you're
adrenaline must be pumping right now holy crap first try yes that was my first
attempt on that map thank you for admitting how amazing wait did I
forget to do a mission
did I forget to do a mission oh I forgot to do a mission completely okay sorry
we need to do hang time I completely forgot to just do an entire mission my
well you've crashed a few parties before but I never expected you to make
it this far if you don't turn back
wow okay okay I can do this I can do and these get these kind of maps are
Molotov cocktails I'm sorry but there's something about the Geneva convention
oh my god a magic carpet right oh
did I just get put in a jar oh wait I forgot these guys so Molotovs already
and a magic carpet I can hardly see that as it comes over right give me a
checkpoint because it's not looking good okay wow isn't this not no I'm gonna put
back here this is so far away I better get check point right now give me a
checkpoint right now
Amy figure when go wait Amy a figurine you'll have to like and subscribe a bit
more for a figurine the thing when oh right okay sorry I'm getting distracted
and if you guys are like serious but like oh when can we get this particular
merch that particular merch the sad thing is and I have to message these
companies and then I basically have to go here's the statistics and here's oh I
almost perished there and it's like I can't go to a company to produce like
merchandise it's like a lot of money and and sorry let me try hard
so one okay that's fine that's fine we got that we got the checkpoint and and I
basically I can't ask for like this merchandise that costs like thousands to
be produced if it's like yeah we've got 4,000 subscribers like it's just not
happening and so you know if you ever want to support your girls just make
some clips of them go viral or something I don't know okay holy crap
whoa this is a risky map I'm not gonna lie this is one more oh bonus map bonus
time um they need a minimum guaranteed return on investment yes like
Ubu market and we're absolutely fantastic because to get and to get I
completely forgot I can double jump half the time
oh there we go and I'm not I don't want to accidentally fall off the map to be
honest I'm quite happy just to move on and yeah like you need to go to the
company and be like this is what we do and this is why we're a good fit for
you here the statistics to back up like and you know such and oh and oh right
you go wait what's that death do I want to go on that one I did just hit a
checkpoint oh no oh no I just I looked an achievement for them get viral get
viral get viral yes and like as I said Ubu market were fantastic because they
gave three designs like they made three designs for the girls and it was like
the girls aren't even out we had absolutely no idea what the estimations
were looking like or the success or whatever and we were my name wonder
they call it the death route right I'm not doing that again I don't think it's
imperative to the plot oh yeah no I'm not fussed for the death row we why he's
got random TNT you got a name but yeah they were like yeah you can have three
designs which was fantastic and if oh oh wait I don't want to touch that cuz it's
TNT I guys just throwing swords over there hey check point right hold on
jump belly float oh wait let's see there so it doesn't blow oh go away you're so
creepy oh yeah is this are you sugar that hurt me
it's okay um
oh I don't like the look at that oh I'm not even in range of it oh my god his
mouth like being wide open while she's climbing oh thank god give me off this
map you have to complete them to get the best ending isn't there not only one
ending where you win this crash bandicoot the game was like that but I've
vomit up there was this enemy Dr. Entropy isn't Entropy when you're
like skinny I'm I think it's not in our way too stupid to understand what you're
getting yourself into this time you've done it
Entropy there's usually a special hundred percent completion and then jump what
does that mean what does that mean what does it mean I don't know
oh
oh take that you you you scallywag ah okay okay okay whoa oh my god the music
oh I actually really like that the boss fights aren't that hard like I said
it I'm sorry I said it sorry if this is gonna age terribly and I'm gonna like
struggle with the next boss fight but I think this is lovely like this is this
is a lovely experience I spoke far too soon I apologize for my ignorance I do I
spoke far too soon I admit it I confess to my sin right let's try that again
okay let's try that again I never made it this far into the game as a child I
don't think I did either because I am I don't recall anything past Coco I just
think that only remember Coco okay okay okay right this time don't let the
missile go to my head so that'd be great okay wow I almost jumped into that
honestly him laughing is so me like if I was an evil person
oh take this
oh to spin longer and faster or to glide while in the air press X repeatedly
wow I love that move first try yeah yeah first try first try first try
you must realize that this time twister machine is very delicate without Dr.
entropy's constant care and control and she's trying to what it will do and she's
trying to guilt truck was into losing who knows what it'll do oh no right we're
back to being a lady because we did the general mission okay we're going to Egypt
to a rabie and now the sphinxinator I want to explore your sphinxinator oh my
god is this is going to the left side of the map now from that previous map no
it's not it's just me making stuff up I'm sorry second gen sphinxinator confirmed
honestly I'm sorry it's not whoa a sarcophagus
and not the good king Blake Azura whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa who o
okay that was terrible tabin can we get like a crossbow maybe okay let's try
that again I don't know when I was supposed to jump for him angle ah maybe
Maybe I was supposed to double jump over the flames, right?
You, and then a mummy, okay, that's fine, return the slime, watching you play this makes me
want to get a spiral, I've never played spiral but people were recommending it and I was like
I might give it a shot, give me checkpoint please but let the doors close first because I was 100%
gonna fall for that, hold on, I want the spikes up, okay, all right I'm safe to go on it for the
section which is fine, that sarcophagus is making some, you're scaring me, I like how it
pings off onto like some of the items to break them for you, oh god I'm so bad at this one,
double jump, okay, we need to wait, spiral is also fun, yeah spiral and crash bandicoot can I get,
are they by like the same developers or was it just they happened to come out
kind of closely the same time, right what did I do wrong here again, I had nothing to protect me,
I'm wondering if I have more time if I do that, oh wow I do, right,
and let me guess that doesn't explode the T, oh no it does, I was gonna be like oh let me guess it
doesn't do anything, again, oh no, oh we're struggling with this one,
goodness gravy, am I making this look easy, no sorry am I making this look hard,
right and then wait for it to come back and then jump on it and then defeat the mummy twice
or the sarcophagi, jeez, let's try this again, right and then I can just double jump here
because I'm out of range and then he's gonna drop that which explodes that one first just fine with
me, right don't send it, don't send it reflings, if you ever replay this game don't send it at
that section because that's what I thought I had to do there and it did not pay off, I need to wait
until he spawns the second blow, we'll get there it just takes me a few moments, can't believe it
they made me flat, the lollipop model confirmed first Ronnie, right again just jump over this
which is fine, oh there's not even TNT this time the game said yeah you're struggling, right send it
send it send it send it right and you would work if I sent it, oh I've got a checkpoint goodness
that'll be very welcomed I assure you, there's really enemies behind this, yeah there's freaking
TNT, oh take your time, take your time, there will be a mummy, okay we're good, we're good, we're
doing it, we're doing it, we are doing it, oh why would they randomly have a natural there
oh oh send it send it send it send it, I like how he just looks at me as if I'm not about to
kablamo him, uh this seems suspiciously easy, rather this is suspiciously, oh wait hold on, oh
crystal let's go on the bonus map, don't send it no idea I'm literally giving you the strats live
because uh I'm struggling, okay there's lots of TNT, I'll just let it pop and then run away again
what oh there's too many oh dear
there's lots of freaking
oh well that's the best I can do, the best I can do is what I've got,
cuckoos don't look at the explosion because she's so cool, I start off a guy, oh I'm just a
bit rude of me but uh I did the job, oh there's like monkeys in these pots, sling your shit elsewhere
oh my god he's quaking, his little ankles are gone, he's quaking in his boots
oh I've got another life, thank you, okay, perish, perish, yeah yeah yeah, start quaking more, boom
I don't know what that does, I think you're supposed to like go back when you do that but
I don't go back, there's a message in the discord, I need to be worried
no everything's fine, okay 17, bye bye blimp, I'm in the sky, oh my god we're playing crimson skies
good game, good game, bye bye blimp, if you ever play crimson skies in an old old game, shoot down
the blimps, I have 100 health, okay, oh I had to shoot, okay machine gun, I need to do a barrel roll
wait I'm already down 10% health, the heck, I only just got started, oh man
I'm going, wait that didn't break it, oh I'm barrel rolling, oh that gives me health,
oh my god this, I like this game, this is so creative, I like it, wow we're getting absolutely
obliterated, not gonna lie, we're about to get survivors bias going on here, that meant, okay wow
I like that, that was nice and simple, more missions like this please, wait not all of us have a hierarchy
you're supposed to destroy every box, the green boxes at the end get rid of the H
oh my god that was such a quick and easy one, I like that, give me more of that, give me more
give me give me more, give me more, tail no tails, oh dead man tell me okay, oh someone said do a
watch along over
Crash Bandicoot, we meet again, Uka Uka and Dr. Cortex want me to teach you a lesson,
wow I made a few more vacations to my mechanics since our last encounter, so back on,
I'm
obliterated
uh oh my god, yeah, oh well okay we did it, we did the ramp, I was like oh I missed the
timing on the ramp, we still did it, oh right we're safe, we're safe, man this freaking game is
just like so unapologetically good, like yeah suck at the racing ones but that's fine, sorry Mr. Seagull
I got pecked to death, oh my gosh, anyway uh as I was saying before I got pecked to death by a
freaking seagull, um this game is like so unapologetically good, like it's such a chaotic
fun experience, it's so good, I didn't know the seagulls could hurt me like that,
I mean is he even there, he's not even here this time, so he didn't really care that much about the boxes,
baby
I'm just like the music, it's so, whoa, that one that's rude, don't do that again, you upset me,
that's just like such a freaking good game experience, honestly, am I gonna land on that bomb, no,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
I probably went like the longest way, I don't know if I had to do that but that was like the longest
way, you're a cuttlefish after all, I'll, I'll cuttle your fish in a minute if you don't, I don't know,
please leave me alone Mr. Shark, I think I'll just do this checkpoint, yeah let's do the checkpoint
because I don't trust this, this is, they're starting to really fill it out with enemies though,
it was like bear the first time you played this map, the bombs were moving, there's like enemies
everywhere, I mean I know games are supposed to, please leave me alone Mr. Seagull,
nope, nope, that bomb is teasing, that bomb is teasing and teasing me,
but this is like a perfect remaster, oh there it is,
that's what we need, oh I don't want to do, I don't have a checkpoint, I don't have a checkpoint,
give me checkpoint, give me, give me checkpoint, give me checkpoint, give me yeah,
oh my god, I just like cheesed that corner there, okay we're getting there, we're getting,
we're like, we're doing it, can I do it first time though, oh, oh I'm getting nervous, oh I don't
know why I did that but we'll do it, oh my god, so good, oh this, I'm so surprised how much I'm
enjoying this, but then at the same time I'll always enjoy kids games like literally Viva
Fina, I could like blast about for ages, okay we just did that one, we're doing 19 which is future
frenzy, oh we're going to the city of Calun, although they wrecked it,
wow there's laser beam timing, I miss Viva Fina, bro everyone is waiting for Viva Fina 3 to be
announced, unfortunately I didn't like Viva Fina about trouble in paradise as much, which is a shame,
oh my god this is so cool, I like all of this, I'm loving it, I'm loving it, I'm loving it,
can I destroy that, okay I can destroy it when it's like that, yeah
that there's like so much, one for fruit, oh my god that nature just jumped and it scared me,
okay, right I can butt bounce this, wait we're already done, no this can't be right,
it's going to take me to a new section because there's no way, yeah I was going to say there's
no way this thing is done, Viva Fina a beast, yes in July I am going to start hammering a
gamer score and why is there a reflective stream, wow
she slides so well, I don't like you, I'll jump on your head though
okay I'll take you, uh double jump, okay double jump, double jump, we're learning
okay just jump over again, okay we're learning, we're learning, we're observing, we're using
our brain mass against her wills, hold on I can double jump over this, oh okay
and then we'll butt bounce that, no we won't, we'll double jump over this, oh I almost messed
it up, oh my god that was the first checkpoint was like so long into this, um on the flyer and
saucer you guys I hate them too, people are waiting for a review with me at a stream to be
announced and I agree, I would want some sort of remaster or get the same dev team in because
we were so precious, go away, oh sugar, let's try that again, go away, wow what, yeah that's
exactly what I thought was gonna happen Coco and I was forced to do that stinky game, that guy's red
and go green, I think, go away, oh
oh I'm to fly, oh right, oh sorry I thought that was gonna explode, wait we'll do the bonus level
I thought that was gonna explode the moment I came near it, okay we're safe, oh no the game's
telling me to like double triple quadruple jumps and stuff, wait well double jump and then
okay we're fine, we're fine, kendo
okay and we got an extra life, double jump, right we're not doing bonus levels anymore
if there's a chance that I can perish in them, I will not stand for such slander, thank you
Vajingo for the five gifted members, shit, and congrats to those who caught it, enjoy the emotes
I have four 10 emotes up for it, wait
I'll just cross, I have um
10 emotes, the girls are getting their batch of 10 before me because the emotes artist
is gonna take a month to do them and I'm crying internally when she told me that because
ouch why a month, it hurts, and they increased the price as well, it sucks even more
because I like when emotes all look the same, like where it's clearly, what the heck am I supposed to do
oh wait was that on note to spam eh?
um
you're a capture, okay
oh man
you don't lose lives in bonus levels though, eh
what am I supposed to do, yeah that's exactly what I just tried to do but it didn't like it, oh sorry I'm like
hanging all these away, so go up and then
Coco, Coco, Coco Chanel, I'm gonna start, I need a word with your manager because what's going on here Coco
I'm double jump and then xxx and then that's exactly what, oh
of course there's a tnt there just to ruin my day
right we're not gonna double jump, oh Coco, Coco
Coco Chanel number five is the top leading women's perfume in sales
just the fun fact
I think it is anyway, right go away
double jump, I don't know why this is getting so hard, right
right so you do it that way, so go and do it that way then, Coco, oh my god why are you not doing it that way
why are you not doing it that way, why are you not doing it that way, you did it the other way, so why won't you do it that way
right double jump, oh sorry I'm like throwing all these apples away, right not apples
so fly and then x, no right that didn't work, so fly up and then, no why
sorry I need to practice doing it this way but it's actually not doing it that way
it's not
right I'm just gonna spam a and x, oh it worked, it worked I literally just spammed a and x
I'm so smart, I don't know what the input controls are supposed to be
you know what, you know what, see this game I have to go do that section all over again
because they put a freaking spike over that jump, oh and I've just lost my wee ugabugamask
bruv, bruv I'm getting ruled
I'll blame it, I'll blame it, my room's actually getting pretty warm right now, right just spam a and x
okay we'll try again, we'll try again, we'll try again
wait does the game know I'm struggling so it gives me a free mask, I was like oh again with the tea the
nitro, my goodness, all right hold on
I don't, I'm trying to observe what I'm doing wrong
okay okay I know not to go now right spikes and jump on his doodoo hair and then jump on that
and then destroy everything and we did it okay jeez that was terrible that was a rough one
the game giving me a free mask because I'm so bad you get the petty mask no
that's terrible but I got the crystal that's the main thing
18 I did that one 19 I just did so 20 oh my god we're getting there
tomb waiter more like womb raider am I right
thank you thank you how many leaves lost now far too many
oh there's scarabs whoa what are you oh okay there's water I guess I drowned in this game
uh right I guess I can't what are you uh no you're freaky
okay that actually worked I don't know how
wah wah wah cool cool can't swim I'm gonna just get a new one
I'll stand on this box and let the water rise
please
please make me tired a bit earlier oh I don't like you oh boy oh for you
yeah yeah yeah that's what I thought right if bonus levels cause me to perish I'm not really that
fast for them okay hold on up go go up before you drown
oh wait did that just go down I did
sorry I'm trying to like peek ahead around the corner of the level to be like hmm what comes up
there oh my god no not now not now wait you don't drown of course you don't drown because why would
you but me I perish oh wait I'm gonna get this life because I'm doing so bad I need the lives I need the
lives getting bonks back and forth right we've got 16 lives just a second right
nitro explodes on contact and got another bonus level oh no that's a death level
oh my god I don't like time missions they make me scared but we made it oh we got the gym
oh right hold on hold on hold on I'm so sorry I would like commentate a bit more but I'm actually
getting stressed out playing this game right I need this platform the timing missions are like the worst
cool cool oh checkpoint right that's all I needed right what are my refunds since I have like hardly
reges at all getting bounced back and forth a staring contest with a freaking game honestly
I believe the science assistants are robots oh my god we're getting the secret hidden lore that I
don't know about whoa what was that up there I saw that don't think I didn't see that exactly what did
I just do wow is it this I just unlocked I think I probably just did that yeah ain't no way I'm
jumping over those nitros they're gonna explode whoa I'm not even bothering to attack him
oh can I make it in time please don't crush me okay I made it I made it oh there's 10 TNT ahead
honestly I did I thought this game was gonna take eight hours but it must be eight hours if you're
100% it and like go back and do everything um
but yeah I think we're probably gonna be redirecting to any of this right if I'm blasting through the
game like this it honestly would do me quite well because I need to go upload the girls ASMR
for them still whoa that her beetle just got absolutely annihilated bonk
yes mersey and aces meme ASMR I'd be told I'm gonna push I'm gonna publish so hopefully they
do quite well right oh let's go cool cool you're doing amazing right we are going against doctor
oh engine oh I get it I get it let's hope I don't parent
so you want to go with your eyes when this is over we'll see who is obsolete
wow my tommy my tommy
eh
eh oh what am I to do I don't know what I'm to do my shirt is willy oh my god
I'm just spraying I'm just spraying staying out the way holy crap the rockets are freaking locking
on to me why is he shooting from his winky though I'm not being funny I don't know what I'm supposed to
shoot at and then I'm getting shot at really badly
this nothing's happening to his health
maybe something's gonna happen after this attack sequence
oh uh oh his winky single oh okay I did it I destroyed his winky oh oh oh oh oh you're hurting
you're hurting okay this one okay okay I see it's coming together it's coming together I just
needed to aim a bit better am I to aim at his guns no this cannot be right although it kind of
looks like I'm supposed to aim at his guns you know that oh but how am I supposed to do that but again
aim that I'm not sure about that this oh it is it is this is guns it's yellow shoot the yellow
oh my god the yellow paint before yellow paint was a thing oh my god crash bandicoot you were
before your time you were truly before your time oh hardly got any licks in on that one
I don't want to get in that way but okay they're both sparking so we're doing good I'll let him get
as we spray out and I'll go up so he can't get me oh wow his thing is like really strong
I can't really spray into him okay there we go there we go there we go one more
oh my god we did it why are oh my god we did it we're so freaking good at this game
oh
pura's gonna help me we love pura
okay I'm literally just doing 360s to try and avoid any enemies and just do like tag damage
oh my god pura is helping me so much
oh my god that thing is getting closer to me whatever that is oh it went behind me
uh what the heck I don't know what's going on with that
oh pura you're helping me so much darling
pura love we love pura out here oh my god yeah
oh we did it to fire fruit at a target hold left mouse button to raise a gun and then aim
with the direction then press B wait I actually do unlock a crossbow in crash bandicoot no way
that's so good I got nervous when I saw a face too not gonna lie I was like oh my confidence is
history repeats itself yet again engine has failed to defeat you
oh my aching head I'm not feeling myself these days so the end is in sight gather another five
crystals and again you will foil my plan or will you he's got veneers
right no we're wait so we're we're falling for his trap if we keep progressing
wait I've got my laptop I'm a laptop I have two laptops you're such an MLG gamer
cool cool we're doing it gone tomorrow news today gone tomorrow that's the saying
are all the levels after a saying or like a pun honestly me cortex is the press for
what's going on here double jumps double jumps
double jumps oh I don't like that wait double jumps I guess you do even like oh I don't like that
that's awfully menacing what do you do
do
oh wait what was this I can unlock now I think I can throw food
cocoa
cocoa what an area sir
cocoa that's offensively large and hilarious oh I didn't mean to do that sorry I like jumped
right into that cocoa that's not even a gun that's a rocket launcher oh my gosh wait does
this make the game like way easier though it does oh my god you see that that aim bought I could
I will safely get past bro cocoa that was so violent honestly she's done asking nicely she's
had enough she's like bro get me out this game and then do what do this and then oh no I'm broke
oh my god I didn't really had a rocket launcher and crash bandicoot I definitely did not get this
far into the game as a child as a wean as a speckle honestly I was probably a molecule
when I was playing this I'm just a bastard bandicoot with a rocket launcher I thought of that mean
but there is like nah there's no way I can bring it up I'll have to let everyone bring it up because
hold on nah I can like aim to the sides like this thank you lord of stroms for the five gifted
membership congrats to those who caught it with your face you'll have to enable membership gifting
you might get a prompt in chat if you don't have it enabled but congrats to those you can use my
muts now wait oh my god I'm getting you oh it's out of bounds off camp wait what
oh my god I can destroy tnt from afar as well I don't know why I went up I couldn't believe
oh my god this makes the game so easy I love it here I love fresh bandicoot
or coco can't bandicoot because coco hog
wow I almost got done congrats on those who caught the the members
oh wow see it worked that time but every other time I try to do the fluffy effect and fly it never
works she didn't manage to do another two games I have never actually played the other two games
so I don't know what the experience is like oh sorry I didn't mean to like get rid of all those
oh my god the game's like so kind it doesn't even go against your like
ammo can I like shoot you no no okay I have to do the dodge
I'm freaking loving this game oh my gosh it's like so well put together other than the recent ones
but because I'm dumb and couldn't figure out
thank you for coming on member and lord of strums again for the gifted membership me and the reeflings
just as I was complaining about a race in the mission
it's the last one though
it's the last race in mission surely
surely two and then go right I got the boost
the police are doing nothing other oh I never even saw that oh my god I need my glasses on so badly
we'd just still love me as a streamer if I never put my
I'm trying to hold it together I'm trying to hold it together I'm at the absurdity that is these maps
for racing I'm literally seventh place there's no way
I there's no way I've got this I refuse yeah get in my way Yabu
okay everyone's using the ramp which is fine I'll use it too okay you're gonna have to use
the ramp because of the bro these AI police cars bro you can't even reverse in this game
the reeflings I'm gonna have to send my game file to one of you right now
and then you send me it back complete and I'll do the other missions while I'm at it
because this is ridiculous uh why did they make the freaking driving one so hard
and crash if you didn't stop skating everywhere across the map we're actually gonna have issues
out my road okay well that was terrible please don't ever do that again
I'm fifth place oh and I missed it
okay the AI can actually go off road which is interesting I didn't know that
the AI is adapting and I'm getting nervous why are they oh and I missed it again
I'm fourth place honestly that wasn't awful I'm wondering right we'll keep doing it we'll
keep doing it we'll keep doing it that was the first time I played the map and the first thing
I did was fall off okay reeflings are always thrilled to princess carry me honestly I just wish
I just I just I'm getting filtered by a child game three two and then hold boost okay and then
on the left side there is already an issue so the AI is actually choosing to go off the map
which is curious I didn't think the AI did such a thing
very curious indeed yeah they're all avoid in the polis
so just take it easy these corners didn't do so yeah I didn't do so hot in these corners
wow I'll take that boost though I'll take that boost thank you
I have to take this ramp because there is a gap you will not make it
go minasori you will not make it if you take that gap it's okay no fender bender fender bender
that's illegal you have to stop and call the police oh fuck this
okay hold on can you fender bender elsewhere please elsewhere okay
okay
I'm trying reeflings I'm actually trying so hard right now I'm sweating my my cheeks off
I say I'm sweating my panties off but you all know what's happening with that oh I might do it
oh my god I might do it oh my god just don't just don't
my mouth is the gate from how hard I'm trying right now
oh oh my god I did it in two oh thank god thank god oh my god that was so freaking hard
literally maximum mouth breathing all all wrinkly parts of my brain were locked in
all the smooth parts of my brain were told to be quiet momentarily oh my goodness gravy thank god
I never have to do a racing mission again victory victory oh lol oh such a good game
I'm sorry I'm absolutely loving this I highly recommend it reeflings if you have
got some money to spare right now and you want to give a gamers hey I was on top of your heat
um I heavily recommend getting the v-master crash band to cook because this is just fun
I have to wait until the nice man goes away and then I don't come back
right flamethrower which is fine oh the guy's gone now see the game helps you if you're rubbish as
well which is even better the game is holding my hand oh my god I can't believe a reefling made
this game just for me because they knew how much I struggle oh my god reeflings you're actually so
selfless it's stunning like you're so polite right we've got a checkpoint what's going on here
okay I made it anyway I don't know what's going on but I made it anyway there's a little thing to
the right I'm tempted to go explore but you know what we'll go explore to the right what's over here
don't think I didn't see that
I thought it was a hidden thing to the right you're and it's not you're telling me it's not a hidden
area to the right bro I'm sorry but reeflings are pranking me I can't believe you got in the
dev team just to prank me bro whoa you see there I want to interact with none of that I want none
of this I want any problems I don't want peace I want to problem me giving myself more work
is literally that mean I don't want peace I want problems
oh
oh no no no no we ain't going we ain't going until you go
Prince Ali mighty is he aliyah oh blah blah
show some respect boy can you oh that's not a platform
okay sorry there's not a platform there
oops
oh and I missed
Ali think Coco just like constant has her laptop on her she's like yeah I need this
honestly it's safe I'm like bro but I need I need internet access the whole thing
okay flamethrower that's fine do not go on the fake platform that isn't a real platform okay
you're gonna be sorely disappointed that to find there's nothing
uh whoa that was actually really lucky timing going on here
I think the camera angles I would at first I actually didn't like that I couldn't control
that camera angle but now I'm like I get it now this is actually pretty pretty nice this is pretty
rewarding
as much as we love bubble a cheeky oh wow
um
how often do you throw right okay I saw him peek and I was like I'm about to get in trouble
uh right jump and then jump again okay we're getting there we're getting there refunds
oh my god an extra life don't mind me the only thing I don't miss from the era is the tank control
oh my god we're absolutely smoking
we're smoking and no tobacco is needed okay
wow so we only got two more levels than the boss five mad bomba bomba deer
here remember your bazooka oh I already forgot I had one crash coco remember it is not only
dr cortex that we battle beware of uka uka my children he is a far more dangerous enemy
than anyone can imagine oh no that's not good
whoa shoot down the bomba deer shoot down the bombers like these planes that can shoot me
oh my god we're committing artillery warfare
get that plane done
I'm gonna just do this
are you a baddie yeah you are okay so I can shoot the enemies as they appear and then I don't get
hit by them okay that's pretty good to know man this one was so far away
okay there we go I can destroy this guy like completely wholeheartedly
I did see someone swan in there but I think we're okay okay there we go
I'll take the health now I don't know if that was a bit too preemptive but we're doing it so
oh I see him I see him I see him I see him I see him
he was gonna become a kazi incident jeez
okay we're getting there we've got two more bomba deers
what sorry the controls are inverted like sorry I'm used to the controls being inverted for
man I'm absolutely smoking sorry I'm actually so good at this child game
like I need head pads for how good I am at destroying this child game
I need accolades to to ever forever recognize me is so good at beating up this game
it's fantastic we did it okay we we almost did it wait hold on let me turn around but let me
just get these guys first turn around every now and then I get to see you oh my goodness oh I'm
getting head pads you're in so good moment good girl I was thinking of sly cold to do
you regularly get the petty math no don't point that out don't tell them that no one needs to
no one needs to know that I don't get the petty mask that much okay
okay I just did that what's this uh a bug late not to be confused with a bug's life
okay you're doing great thank you refling this game's absolutely fantastic I cannot recommend
this enough I might actually recommend the girls play it just because you don't really need any
previous knowledge other than that first dinosaur like I was having a stroke trying to figure out
how to get the dinosaur to not coblame on me
um yeah I've got like a little guide for the girls that like has a list of the games that
they can play and like on based on complexity but I actually need to make it a much better list
because I need to like add like how long it takes to play or these temporary areas oh it's Navi
oh wait oh oh my god I have my own light source it's beautiful
okay double jump x and we'll see oh this is beautiful
another light for me oh he got tired he needs to go to bed that's okay you don't have you don't
have to do this for your entire life oh I keep throwing my apples away oopsie
hmm how far away did I just get put back oh I'll get masked right next to this one point
stronti's doing fine but the most important thing is she's enjoying herself everyone's happy
stream is bliss oh that's so precious I'm glad you guys are happy
oh I keep throwing away me me one for fruit
okay you can now go into retirement and then I'll take you
and then what did I do wrong here I already forgot was it
no Coco you're spinning everywhere okay jump and then double jump see nice and simple
biggest enemies are literally jumping in this game no other reasons okay there we go
whoa no it's dark um oh
hello I cannot see I cannot see please do not leave me alone oh okay
wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow
oh my god oh my god I'm so MLG pro you literally can't stop me
how long does this last for
oh it literally ended just as I walloped that enemy holy crap
okay let's try that game oh and we got a checkpoint thank you Zengu99 for becoming a member I appreciate
it uh membership streams do start oh why is it so dark I can't see um membership streams start
night how on earth am I supposed to deal with all of them
just to go for it
uh they start next week and I will show you the schedule the plan the duke oh wow actually
well looked in uh everything is shown on
oh ouchie I hurt myself uh on fucking the buckshot roulette my goodness sorry I'm really
trying to speak in I can't do two things at once oh my god we did it bro all these missions are so
fantastic oh I can't see for shit and there's a jump ahead of me oh if we're gonna say I couldn't
see at all let Latina forward thank you for becoming a member um
oh boss fight oh okay I can't believe you're playing Crash Bandicoot I'm playing childhood
games although I only remember Coco and the tiger and the tiger's name Dr. Neo Cortex
whoa boss fight already oh they really said guys almost warped it's you know
hi scrawny can't believe you are playing one of my favorite childhood games I have been trying
to do one childhood game this is the part where I'm supposed to be angry full of rage incensed
beyond belief once again you have outsmarted and outspun my best pension I should be rather
upset shouldn't I and in fact we're glorious it seems we're all of one small detail little
orange delivery boy now that we've gathered all the crystals all we have to do is take them from you
all these missions are fantastic immediate criticism of the light in
oh no oh no oh my god they're battling it out the tiki masks are going for it
what I do what I do oh I need to jump over it oh I need to jump over their laser beam if they get
in the way oh tiki man's trying to help me out but the baddie is all the way why you're putting
yo c4 why are you putting c4 on the ground
oh wait oh no I was supposed to wall up him his shield was down I'm sorry I missed a cue
I don't I don't think I ever I highly doubt I actually got past the second stage
I could I didn't really remember anything right he throws these and they explode and his shield was
there what does it mean go in go in go in go in okay okay okay we've got it we know what the
mechanic is am I to go in no okay I was actually about to go in that hole I'm not gonna lie okay
they're gonna battle now oh no it's candy floss is ultimate from the hit game comfort chaos
okay right when he puts mines then that's when I can make a move okay now I don't know if the AI
locks onto me oh my god oh get in in the hole in the hole in the hole in the hole in the hole in the
hole right oh my god we're doing and we're gonna do it we flings I've never finished this game I was
like saying I get to finish it with you we're gonna do it whoa whoa whoa okay they're doing
oh they're doing different moves oh this is dangerous this is very dangerous
oh no no no no don't do that okay okay it's fine we're safe okay he's throwing the mines
okay okay okay okay okay okay let him get up let him get up get in the hole get in the hole do it do it do it do it do it
she's a hegeo she's even uh oh wait why am I getting an ability you run faster holding down right
trigger while running wait this isn't the end of the game
the monkey is there's more
defeated again this is not fair maybe I should retire to a nice big beach
with a nice big drink to the bahamut with nice big bags of ice for my head
wait a minute
I did it he was talking about Tati Voljangles
we did it oh my god that was such an amazing game I'm clapping for myself I'm for you
oh my gosh what a fantastic game it's so goofy it's so fun it's so beautiful
hey what that was just an amazing game all around that was a 10 out of 10 experience
I heavily recommend you to play that if you've never played it before
oh it's so good I clap clap clap clap clap oh my god producers no thank you
Kayle Martin for coming to the designers for crashing Coco thank you Justin Hesler that was
fantastic level designers Andy maybe not thank you to you because I know you did that dinosaur one
what was that that was not me burping for once for once the game burped that took me completely I
was doing character artists thank you corey turner lead animator Curtis or more like Curtis
smashed at 10 out of 10 visual effects artists rich Magan fantastic UI artists Kara Zezas we
could not have done it without you engineers my goodness your alchemy engineers Alan Abrams thank
you alchemy senior producer Coy burden you earned that senior position role 10 out of 10 thank you
Tim Tillotson don't think I wouldn't forget you senior data analysts look you analyze that data
far beyond expectations audio designers Matt Pirog oh your audio was 10 out of 10
the way the SFX was fantastic congratulations on beating the game
pen penitent thank you for the tip and thank you for congratulating me on the finish in the
child's game the VV backbone not to be confused with the globally well-known VTuber VV the ASMR
ASMR the Australian VTuber let's go VV um but how could we have done it without you it administrator
Anthony Rocicotio we're so thankful recruitment coordinator Blair you recruited out the wazoo
user testing Johnny Reed thank you for finding that bug on that one map and getting it written out
fantastic VV babies oh my god development actual development teams children's names
congrats on all being birthed from the lines of your parents that are on the development team
of crash band acute warped remastered additional development support for toys for Bob oh Mike
Albert we could not have done it without you and a very special thank you to naughty dog Dan airy
fantastic truly truly with an additional special thanks to none other than David Siller himself
and a special thanks to shout out to all regional team members and Activision you've run a few games
into the ground but this one you did 10 out of 10 on so I'll let it slide for once
um archivist Heather we love a good archiver shout out to archive anon Heather and other
archive annons that may be out there you worked diligently in the dark to serve the light yes
that's an assassin's brother brotherhood just reference oh my goodness golly what whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa wait he didn't go whoa whoa whoa whoa i'm pretty sure crash band acute supposed to
go whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa time for more children's games oh viva pinata is coming up and so is
cameo as i said in july i'm gonna focus on nailing down some gamer score because i don't know what
happened to skyrim i don't know why it wasn't popping we might return back to skyrim actually
wow there's so many noises a bluey game win a bluey game what's the bluey game
i'm so sorry i don't know what a bluey game is time yeah stroney you set a perfect whoa
i'm pretty sure he goes because there's loads of memes of him going
whoa bluey inside oh the show bluey that's for ozzy's
can you get the blue bluey inside activision publish yeah yeah yeah okay well let it slide
activision thank you to the market and team josh to have uh your advertisement didn't come to me
but i just knew about this game from childhood so shout out to you laces and in partnerships we
love a good licensing out here thank you for lacing crash bandicoot so i could enjoy it to its full
extent uh supply chain operations tom benny we couldn't have done it without you enjoy that
senior director position you earned it hopefully it was not uh uh nepotism higher but you know what
will let it slide for this game this experience the ost i am gen three background music is going to
be crash bandicoot ost i'm not even i'm not even gonna tell any lies or any scoobies i am blown away
by this game obviously i had a chance to play it in childhood so there was a lot of nostalgia
associated with the game but this was nothing but a short of fantastic a lovely experience
truly the game didn't feel feel like it was going on too long if you enjoy it you can also a hundred
percent it um just 10 out of 10 all-round type of game for me helps with a short attention span
helps that was designed for kids to play helps that was beautiful colorful um everything was so
interactive do you have any plans to play the newest crash game crash for it's about time i've
never played it um but i would understand why not if it's anything if any of the other crash games
are like this that they're quick wham bam they've got fun little interactive mini games inside like
the different levels sure i will a hundred percent play the rest of crash bandicoot um oh my god senior
it networked physician fergus beautiful voiceover production shout out to the v a's loved it casting
director julia bianco more like julia you absolutely blew it out of the water thank you julia and then
there's crash team recent i ain't playing no i ain't playing no driving games the soundtrack to the
ost gods themselves thank you fantastic shout out to crash yeah
you need to play the spiral games oh easy child game friendly short optional 100 percent in
count me in yeah crash four is actually pretty hard okay maybe not maybe we'll just pause on crash
four i'm just for now yes go viral would be fun oh spiral is even easier than this spiral is super
easy when's the pizza tower stream i don't even know what that is i hope in the end of credits
and it says and thank you the fans i'm allowed to say a spoiler for the video game the vealer video
game sure say the spoiler okay this is for only people who are watching the stream at the end
of the vealer video game you hear a voiceline from all of us and we say and thank you the player
after you have just put one hand at our game because i love it so much in video games i was like
i'm having it in this game trial wait are these speed runners no trial testers one hour wait why
is it showing time i don't know what the times are for cute let's go yeah after we've finished the
game literally all of us come on and we all go thank you the player and oh these are the devs
are these the speed run times that's outrageous did they all no it can't be this is 12 minutes
no one has completed the game maybe speed run now 12 minutes would be broken the game
the other game is designed to play one-handed oh it absolutely is we can we can hardly even talk
about it i'm going to get the girls to record them playing it um and then they'll upload it to their
alt twitters so they can like play it for the first time and experience it it's pair map the map
names were on the left my apologies oh my gosh 10 out of 10 experience what a magnificent game what a
well-rounded no wonder they remastered it so what does this do interacts swap hero save load that's
we'll see um yeah wow just 10 out of 10 oh wait what did i just do oh did i accidentally just
load over my save oops oopsies oh well it's fine we finished the game anyway i think i might
mess up a little bit there but it's okay i think i undid all my progress oopsies i undid all my
progress that's too busy yapping um don't worry though uh we all make mistakes
uh yeah no that's well there's no point in saving because i'm already saved up oh well it's fine
it's fine that was fantastic right i'm going to check if there's any veal or girlies on
um i understand that this is a shorter stream i thought it was going to be an eight hour stream
but i was wrong um but uh in exchange uh in exchange for a shorter stream my darling grieflings
mersey and aces meme asomar is going to be uploaded at a certain time it might be timed
after the stream because i think mersey asked for me to make sure it's after she finished streaming
she's gonna end up all savings over the 30% also no no no no no emmy is up in an hour that's
perfectly fine with me um oh pardon me for being so rude i just burped there don't mind me
oh no i got kicked out of my youtube account shoot hold on i need a fucking message management
from my password um just need to message uh what is my youtube password please i'm locked out
i'm locked out i don't know why i locked me out um oh do excuse me i hope that i hope that's not
youtube fucking doing something okay okay with my account better no be right let me go to a
chatting stream dive have a what it's me it's me oh my god it's me right i'll put some background
music on that was such an amazing time oh my god i can't go for that right emmy is going to be up
in t minus t minus what t minus what uh an hour oh my god i have no hour to yeah don't mind if i do
oops no i definitely do not want to end stream from the dashboard please don't give me that option
that scared me don't do that again youtube please don't do that again you're stressing me out
i'm just gonna make sure i'm redirecting into emmy beezo because her monetization stream
is monetization celebration celebration what monetization celebration i give up i give up
emmy emmy emmy monetization celebration
yes okay it says save so when i end my stream god i can't get over how fantastic that game was
uh what's going on
um
what have i got so many comments on that new ASMR video will i show you the stats again
i'll show you the stats on that i don't know i hopefully i'm praying that the girls's mean videos
also get as popular as mine because that that got really popular for like no reason oh my god i
don't want to brag or anything hold on let me let me screenshot so i can show you guys the dirty
details the dirty details the the oh sorry i just flashed behind myself trying to save this file save
file that one uh actually i can just take off the reactive model that's probably a bit better of
an idea don't you think reefland wait so it's just a zero i um right hold on how do i show
you how do i show this on desktop um
what did i call the file i've already forgotten the file name
oh there there okay so this is what it said oh it's there you on a bit big a bit big
this is what it says now on that video says congrats you have 34 000 views bro
yeah i definitely got picked up in the algorithm because i only had 5000 subscribers
it says i earned 780 subscribers from it sheesh my that video alone reached youtube's monetization
watch time uh thingies it literally says 3000 watch hours that's how much you need to get
monetized you need that one video alone you need 500 subscribers and 3000 watch hours that one video
alone i could submit for monetization that's insane uh and also of course i'm breaking the
bank uh 20 please don't be don't be surprised when the 3d models come out next week because
my asmr is raking in the money no there's no 3d vtuber streams coming up just yet
it cost a pretty penny to get that stuff kind of dealt with um
yes there will be signs yes there will be signs um but yeah that video definitely uh is getting about
that was fantastic i can't believe it it's like yacht soon absolutely not i have no desire for a
yacht that is i've i just never had an interest in that kind of thing at all right i want to open
up marshmallow but last time i opened it up it had lots of debuts uh right let me i will link
my marshmallow so you're freaking are you squinting me right now it's brian it's not that it was
pentas dorkin uh it was uh thank you oh marin something for the super chat it was me asking
to hold it while you tinkall it's not pentas dorking the next auto i upload is very no i'm
i'm i'm i'm missing i'm teasing i'm breezing for a teasing dear mommy next time you go on a tinfoil
app can i join you on stream wait have you have you put a little tinfoil hat on a reefling
oh my little reeflings have a tinfoil hat you're so cute let me put it on right now hold on
next time i go for a wee rant this is i'm gonna put you right next to me right here on my right
here oh wait no hold on hold on hold on hold on i can do i can do you a step even better than that
hold hold pause pause pause don't breathe
okay you can breathe you can breathe again wow wow look it's me and the reeflings we're gonna
take them black ropes together you're so good oh my god reefling you're actually so well placed
i can probably do this that reefling literally i know
thank you for your helpful advice some events happened that would have hurt a lot more if i
hadn't thought of you what you told me you give me strength oh i don't know what advice i gave but
i'm glad it could help in the moment you are very strong your is some sometimes you could actually
say you're as strong as your weakest days because on your weakest days you just want to give up but
you didn't so you're as strong as your weakest days does that make sense i don't know maybe it does
keep your keep your chin up reefling your headset's falling off king okay come on we gamers out here
we memeers we're just memeers we meme are low away no it does not it looks like a hair she's
kissed leave my hair she kissed addicted reefling alone heart's full balls empty should be a bit
a vealer's official catchphrase that's amazing oh bucket tape thank you for becoming a member
at membership streams are revealed next tomorrow in the next 24 hours you will know
oh you will know um but yeah
oh my mouse see you it's because of not actually right hold on let me i'll tell you some lore
in a minute the reason my mouse does that is because the light is very low as well as i've
actually not synced up my vtuber model nari rigged me so well like she made me so well i actually
haven't gone into the calibrations to make strony like the the the mecca like reactive to the
microphone or whatever um so like nari is just that good i love your fangs oh yeah do you love
them enough to you know let me in your frankfurt uh right let me get my wee marshmallow link
where did i even send the marshmallow link i don't even think i did oh my god i'm gatekeeping
my own marshmallow terrible can you see wow you guys can tell that i am not all there in the head
from that message i am not all there in the head but that's okay oh yes you're with strony no strony
yes why would you say no to me you're not supposed to say no to me you know what happens when you say no
death but that part comes later not yet soon but yes um it is a smaller stream
but the smaller stream i actually thought it was gonna be eight hours but because it's not eight
hours i'm actually gonna have the energy to go edit so i might have my first thank you for 1000
audio uploaded on youtube on here for free all yours all yours i will also upload the audio
file to patreon as a archive to make sure nothing is lost to time itself um and i will take it from
there my next patreon audio should technically actually be uploaded on the 22nd but i'm not
gonna do that i'm gonna let it be a bit funny i'm gonna the first month on patreon is funny you
still get four audios on patreon but they're just a bit funky they're spaced out a bit weird uh
gman stew thank you for coming i'm mem bye what happens when we say no you get hypnotized
you don't have a choice you don't have a choice and i don't i don't care i don't care if that
sounds r-wordy you don't have a choice but you you'll you'll come to learn to like that you don't
have a choice that's terrible i can't say that stuff out loud and yet i do what happens next
what happens next outrageous streamer says something outrageous oh oh no okay
uh glad you enjoyed my three page story it was so good maybe can i maybe read it i'm gonna see if i
can read it okay stroney has just finished taking a shower and calls her wreathlings into her room
hi there wreathlings stroney said oh in a sultry voice hi there wreathling stroney says in a sultry
voice mommy is ovulating and it's time for a new gen can you all last long enough to satisfy me
and get the job done she drops her towel and lies down on the bed wreathlings approach slowly
sliding a tentacle or two up strong i don't think i can read this i don't think i can read this i'm
like i don't think i can substitute slowly sliding a tentacle or two up strong his legs
and arms and across her stomach massaging her body so she can relax after a long stream she just
finished eventually some wrap their tent i can't read the rest of it i guess really i guess really
but um i wouldn't actually mind if you guys want to send me like little mini scripts like that i
honestly wouldn't mind just reading them and then putting them on the alt twitter just for fun just
for a little uh something something i can't be here then somewhere please yes um it was a very
cute story about how gen 2 is going to be produced with me and the wreathlings um i honestly don't
mind i find that stuff adorable and my voice isn't too fried right now so i might be able to do it
today um do let me cook though but yes you guys are welcome um for me i don't know the comfort
level of the girls yet so please don't apply what i am comfortable with to the girls they are
their own individuals they are their own creatives but if you guys ever want to send me a short script
and just say please mummy um or if you commission an artwork of me um you know a strong so you're
welcome to say i uh ordered you know i saw this fan art and i came up with this script if you
want to combine the two together please do and put it on the alt twitter i am happy to do that i
am very open to this so um and it's completely free to access i will not you know pay a wallet
not not not my job but i won't put i won't pay wall um like little short scripts and fun fans
submitted uh stuff i'm a fan i don't like the word fan you're not a fan you're my wreathling
have the girls heard of the tinfoil rant rants if so what's the reaction oh i'm too embarrassed to
tell them um i'm too embarrassed to like tell them how much i like despise debt and credit cards and
how like the economy is rigged against them especially because like um they may or may not
live in america which makes it even like everything is against them like she be told this story about
her crashing a car and then she jumped off a cliff or something i'm like yeah i'm too embarrassed to
tell the girls that part i just say to them like oh you're doing great um uh i just need this a some
more script from you i'll edit the rest you guys just have fun it's too late for me it's over two
weeks and i hear your voice in my head all the time have i successfully mind broken you do your
wreathling why do you act like you don't want to let it happen let me see into every part of you
until it's all me
glad i could mind break you though i've not even done that part of the hypnosis yet
i mean we ain't even done the tear list yet where i explain in detail every scenario i want to do to you
because of that tag
hydration check
strongy you make me fragile when you talk like that that's why i do it
they're gonna be a little me mark and be all happy and stuff but i do like the juxtaposition
as well as many other positions hold on a minute thank you
here all week dear mommy oh i did beat that one
oh wow someone's analizing my ovulation cycle so a normal ovulation cycle lasts about 24 hours
each month this is correct once an egg is released from an ovary it will dissolve within 12 to 24 hours
if it's not fertilized and the window is about a week before ovulation since it survives for
almost a week so basically if i was trying to fertilize you i would need to do it the day before
for optimum success chance which means the 13th of the month i'll refling you went gen 2 already
you missed your window of opportunity you're gonna have to try again next month with me huh
and we'll just keep trying and trying and trying
uh okay we did it
hi strawney hi replaying just wanted to say that i appreciate your content so far
well i absolutely continue support oh thank you i'm glad i'm glad uh i'm a bit nervous
sending you my first marshmallow oh don't worry i don't bite hard uh but i'll be sure to send you
some more stuff in the future quick question any advice for aspiring script writers make sure to
smash that like button and subscribe to my marshmallow account for more content what what does
that mean um any advice for aspiring script writers consume content and then do what you like
the easiest way for things to naturally occur and now then again i am i have a raging uh
tism over things which helps me like just absolutely work out the wazoo um whenever i'm
presented with a new special interest uh that i'm being educated about i will consume multiple
videos of that content i will i'll put them in times too so i can uh understand the language
that's being used the scenario or situation um and then i just say i like this part but i didn't
like this part i will do this and i will do that and make it my own that's basically how i
attempt scripts it's not that it's not like saying honestly the behind the scenes is rather boring
hmm do risky things happen on membership stream i don't know we're doing a tag rating stream
uh for my first stream i've never done a watch along um i think we're actually watching transformers
the first transformers were sam witt wookie sam congrats if you name sam by the way but
his name is sam witt wicky his marshmallow cherry yank my cherry now
we flings have six tentacles you have eight you have eight arms but you make a little
lot of love heart uh with your front tentacles because we love each other and you got your
little nicotine patch with actual cannibal shy and the buff the o7 movie yeah like it's like
was she a love of shy a love of sorry she uh she and love um did you enjoy the philian fanfic
i don't know where the location of that was
you know stroney my phone broke recently and all it did was glow green and start moving up
and down kind of like when you start glowing it reminds me of you your phone broke i'm literally
hacking into your technology right now so you become even more obsessed it's working the nicotine
patch subdues you for a little bit but unfortunately i get a bit too intense which is why i need to
subdue you editing a silly burp compilation of one of the girls what do you think uh yeah i don't
see why not i'm not being funny someone said that uh she be let out a toot i didn't i'm gonna
freaking message she be after the stream and be like can i clip your toot because whenever
uh a toot gets clipped um all of a sudden um it's like super funny and ha ha and all of that
and so literally the start of the short is gonna be like brian tts being like vtuber accidentally
farts on stream and and play the clip and then oh oh 100 000 views please please give she be a
cabillion subscribers yeah need to go ask the girls literally i need to go put in the discord
if any of you have farted uh please let me know so i can clip it if you're comfortable let's be
clipping it oh my god edit my gen mates part oh what a weird timeline we live in my ancestors
were peasants working in the fields if only they knew that the one who surpassed like the bloodline
ends up editing a toot do you think my ancestors would laugh at that or they'd just be like what
is going on over there they're like no i can't handle this oh the archive of our own link no i
didn't read it yeah i got a bit nervous because i don't know what archive of our own is i think it's
just for text and stuff um i'm sorry mummy but when you rage at games i think of you
are wording me with that passion a wreath playing i don't think we're allowed to say that out loud
but that's hot that's amazing have you ever played metal gear before i haven't um is it easy
if it's easy i'll play it is there a story mode for gamers like me
he's just the one that's saying it out loud wait post that meme where it's the guy like standing up
hold on wait standing up meme guy uh he's like standing up in a courtroom oh my god i've got it
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on wait let me make the meme let me make the meme no one
say a thing or i'm gonna forget how to make the meme okay i've got the jpeg and then i need to open
up an ms pane hold on let me open up the picture in ms pane no one say a thing okay let me cook
let me cook let me cook let me cook this is so bad this is terrible
reeflings you're such a naughty influence on me
okay it's not gonna work i mean i think it's gonna work yeah okay it's working
you can tell of me there's an ms pane oh my god hold on right you ready for this are you ready
oh yeah lost it oh no it's like we're down here this is literally
oh no a thing a thing thank you for the tip slice saver
reefling you're standing up against the masses you're so brave for saying that part out loud
that's so terrible i hope no other beach ever comes in stream and sees that oh my god that's
terrible why are we like this together we bring out the worst side in each other like the the
degenerate side in each other honestly um are you gonna take the but it's a little test again
yeah i'll take it um we can 100% do that stuff i have no problem with that stuff
whereas you mean best he speaks the truth and they hated him for he spoke the truth i can't
i'm not gonna add it into that jesus meme uh hi stroney i want you to bite me all over and leave
marks all over me including on my tentacle i wouldn't do it hard okay i wouldn't do it hard
i would do it to a degree okay i'm all caught up with marshmallows so i'm just gonna be staring
at you now chat what are you gonna do about it huh what are you gonna do sorry i'm burping away over
here we're a match made in something probably not heaven because we can't make it into heaven
with this stuff that we go on about we can't make it into heaven oh no stare back
i feel like i could uh i'm terrible at blinking contests i remember everyone in the playground
was like oh i do do stare contest and i would always lose because i suck i'm already in heaven
no need to go elsewhere will the member streams be archived i may not be able to tune in i'm not
gonna try and get them banned no i think we'll be okay we're gonna use our euphemisms where i go
tentacle and ink and i want to ink on the tentacle because we're cuttlefish out here we're cephalopods
but together we're a cephalopog because we're so cool like that yeah pogger
um have i ever heard about the gates by asa rock i'm so sorry i've never heard of that in my
life we're all stuck in perigatory keep that in mind because there may or may not be a collab
with a va and all villa members that is related to purgatory so keep that in mind
funny you brought a funny you brought that up yeah um imagine pieta but it's the virgin marie
given jesus whoa we we can't be saying that stuff out loud those are inside thoughts
so oh sounds interesting yeah you better be excited
i like when strony spoils i try my best i do i the dust is definitely settling on my list of
stuff to do like a lot of things are becoming a lot easier um and it's getting to the point where i
can fully be strummer yes i can be strummer um i i wouldn't mind having a clip manager but sadly um
i don't have anyone um i trust to be in that position um because clip manager needs access
to the girls accounts to see what people have been clipping and it ain't gonna happen so
unfortunately i am still clip manager at this point in time but it's not too bad because literally
i just take a clip and then i send it to editor then editor comes back and then i upload it on
girls channel and it's all hunky dory stop problem strummer i like when strony you didn't finish your
sentence mommy protecting her doors yes um i will be your shield i know not a lot you play
Overwatch i used to play it quite a lot sadly i fell out of love with it um when Overwatch 2 came
out but uh there is a girl called Brigitte Lentol and her slogan is i will be your shield and yes
i am Brigitte for my gen mates because i don't want anything happening to them um so i'm the i
am both the owl and the shield i love when strony does anything yes uh tomorrow's stream
i'm gonna see if i can get my heart rate monitor working um so i should be able to do that and
then you can see my heart rate during buckshot roulette i didn't manage to watch any more
cultural content because i literally i finished stream i did i see an me's memberships and then
then what would i do i don't know um and then i went on twitter i think i liked one thing and
then passed out and then i woke up like 45 minutes before stream i probably needed a big
sleep like that like it was coming it was coming that i needed a sleep like that
strony that was the whole scene wait what was the scene that's the whole scene
i also like when strony i do like when strony but why are clips private i don't know youtube
doesn't let people see what people have clipped on uh livestream or any content really if it was
public then i could get a clip master but i can't get a clip master because they're not public
but hopefully youtube changes that in a couple of months because that would then negate me even
needing to be a clip master um and then i can spend even more time we're briefly wait they're not
do you remember sending marshmallows to the girls i remember completely crashing on yesterday's
stream for anyone who wasn't watching the runescape stream i hit the 11 hour mark and became
delirious i spilled all my chips on the floor when i ended stream and i just left them until
this morning to clean up eat i was gone with the wind i i don't know what happened i ate food
and i was like oh this will wake me up this will wake me up no it freaking didn't day one day we'll
hit 12 hours for old school runescape honestly um no i didn't have any issues with it playing it but
i like completely crashed the ending of the stream was so funny i just remember being like oh let me
send the girl some marshmallows and then i started typing and i don't really remember what the contents
of it were but hopefully all is good um but yeah i remember just drinking losing it basically
i crashed way before that part of stream you used up all your energy trying to win connect for
unironically oh my god you if you didn't see runescape stream quick recap in runescape you
can play connect for i was getting decimated like the reeflings were like ganging up on me just
fucking one at a time one after the other like bro i just accepted my fate i could not win at connect
one i won one because i tried so hard and burnt my brain the second one i won by accident because
a reefling couldn't see what i was doing um i was gonna absolutely destroy yeah i remember my
sleep fading and then some strange noises coming up um sounds like a fun time bro i was perishing
i don't know what happened because normally i can last 12 hours and i had an eight hour sleep
before it but my brain oh my stomach just made a noise have you heard that my brain just perished
like it had enough it was like i'm sorry i can't hold out anymore checkers oh no i'm not playing
checkers again that was the most confusing thing i couldn't even bro we were playing checkers and i
couldn't even move on the board because i didn't know what was like going on um with the dang thing
it was a redonkiller hold on i'm just gonna pin the marshmallow oh my god that's me
that sounds like that q and a i say q and a is if we don't just like that's not the q and a
length hold on a minute that's the that's what the reefling said wait a minute who are you
i need to straw any cows there we go that's a bit of q and a q and maybe boom it's not really a
q and a is that it's just you guys being lovely to me and then i go in a ramble and i see how lovely
um it is to be here straw knee leaks oh no i sent it to myself now oh no i've been discovered
i send myself all these marshmallows i fell asleep to your stream and my brother was very
much questioning what on earth you were watching when you woke up just me raging
i choked on my burrito region actually which was that makes it like 10 times funnier so
and then i'm rage hi mommy i don't know what to ask but i really love watching you oh i'm glad
you're so funny bro you're giving me an ego we all know the forbidden rule
just genuinely entertaining in more ways than when i yeah your streams always make me smile and giggle
oh you have any giggle mate please keep it up te amo hermosa much love from port arrico te amo
port arrico come to brazil no i'm not going to brazil but thank you for inviting me no thank you
for the nice uh little message how do you feel about the dragon age games particularly the upcoming
veil guard game um i've never played a dragon quest game properly sorry a dragon age game
properly uh i played the one where brother and sister and then brother like immediately well i
said for the brother or die i think uh i played it for like 30 minutes and i was like oh this ain't
for me um but there seems to be quite a lot of fans that are distraught at the reveal because
they don't like it but i thought it was just uh i think why do we hate brazil no it's a meme
where it's like oh come to brazil do a concert in brazil but brazil's really dangerous for foreigners
we don't actually hate brazil hi starney i agree with that one riff riefling when you rage i always
think of you pinning me down and having your your way with me and then not stopping even
when i finish oh my god rieflings this is good i don't think we could say any of this out loud
what if i'm here because i was hypnotized by a moment maybe the hypnosis is listening up
we should hypnotize more not yet you have to wait you have to wait soon it's overtism we're hitting
overdrive what was that stream song overdrive burning machine oh brain power that's it brain power
oh do do do do do do do
how did you decide which of the generation one one models were going to be used
where are there other people auditioning for strawney no um if you weren't there at the start
development all six models were laid out on the website under the auditions page uh i was codename
inks and it said i am a pre-selected talent but please apply to be my gen mate uh no one
could apply for strawney because i'm strawney there is only gonna be one strawney you can't you can't
get better than me okay uh welcome to the danger zone ora ora um as for who did i pick uh uh the
models for i did take into account what the girls went for but when i heard the girls voices
pretty much instantly my brain went oh okay that's gonna be enemy oh okay that's definitely
i say oh okay that's mercy oh that's our genre oh that's she be um because i got to hear them talk
in general in the introduction introduce yourself video and they gave me a good indication of
personality type and all that so if anyone wants to complain uh you you hired wrong you put someone
on the wrong shut shut don't want to hear it do you don't want to hear it uh for a siren that can't
sing you just need to ramble and yap and i'll follow you under the waves i don't actually want you to
perish it was the concept artist that gave me that lore i don't want anyone to perish
can you say shut one more time shut
and you put the girl on the right shut don't want to hear it don't want to hear it give i'll give
you gills yeah you got a good voice to listen to oh yeah i'm a rambling you to sleep oh dear
we fly let's stay to sleep and listen to my voice as i ramble you to sleep
stroney doesn't perish she just beats on you like the water helps with the things i need to do to you
okay seven days no ink help please how has it been so long i say that as if i'm not backed up but
how what do you mean help help uh this kind of help is that the help you need
uh is that what you need i don't know what help you need you didn't specify you got to specify
or i'm not gonna come up with them one hi stroney are there any talents of corpus you'd like you'd
like or veal or to collab within the future i'm humping new me plus and i'm humping v and you
because they were lovely um methos tal hq were very receptive to us as well sadly due to timing
couldn't do the watch longs but uh methos tal seemed to be kind of already leaning on the
alternative side which makes me quite comfortable with them as creators as for actual corporation
tubers uh i'm just if the person's happy with me i'm happy with them i never want to encroach
myself on someone and that's not the word at all i agree with those other two reef flings need
mummy to take all that rage out of my tentacle until it's ink to dry oh my god um mummy if one
were to eventually build up the courage for an audio debut oh my anything you would like to hear
in specific uh or should i just let the imagination go wild any time no have fun i eagerly await your
reef fling
where did you were all this time are you are you trolling me where did you were all this time
where was i for all this time it took me a year to cook veal or give me i needed to be in the
kitchen i'm no the best at it i'm level 76 right now but it takes it takes a long time um so i was
working hard or hardly working you know we love to see a reefing pelt of his courage uh i could
look he go for some water right now y'all should hydrate hydration check i actually i'm gonna finish
my cola um
um
what's what sort of settings would you say are the most appealing and audio booths uh
granting i'm here that uh i want that one your legs to be numb by the end of it
haha are pleading i'm gonna be like mommy mommy mommy mommy
i'm hydrating okay i will hydrate with my beer is it the weekend oh it is the weekend you're
allowed to have a beer right the time right the time are you squinting me
wow and on hello mommy you were a very cute last night when you were sleeping i hope you got
enough rest i did get my tentacles have been thoroughly inked ever since you came into my life
oh i'm glad you think so reefing thank you anonymous for the tip thanks for your tip anonymous
thank you i appreciate it i'm glad you have been thoroughly de-inked
ramura ramura thank you for becoming a member ramura any ramura member i can't say a member
member i'm not really into this type of stuff but for your birthday as a present you can
use a figurine on me for me you'd let me do that okay october 10th is my birthday so make sure
you're all ready for what happens on october 10th are there any more indulge clamps planned in the
future oh boy yeah next week you will be indulged out the wazoo if you mean six-man indulge collabs
i am going to ask the girls if possible that we do one collab a month together of just hilarity
ensuing um i do ah what's that game um it's hard because there's not a lot of six-man games so i
think it might have to be stuff like among us or lethal company i know residency for everyone
plays it but the problem is there's six of us there were many i think there's a back rooms game
that we can play together possibly um i do want to do monthly six-man collabs but after that um
it will be like two on two collabs maybe three three collabs angry scottish drunk karaoke went
soon i was gonna do a drunk karaoke um on um i don't know when i don't know when um but i was
going to do it on a weekend so like you guys can you know work work hard and then get all the relief
on the weekend and we get steamboats and all that when the talents are sourced jackbox would be great
but just with only one pop so you don't have to stream discord yes i am open to doing that um shebe
when we were first meeting for the first time i got the girls to play a game together and we
played jackbox and we all got addicted and we're like stuck i was like because it was only supposed
to be like a one hour icebreaker so the girls could get used to like each other because like from my
pov i knew the girls like i had consumed their content i knew kind of about them who they are
how they kind of are and all that jazz um and then we ended up playing for like two hours and i'm
like oh i'm so sorry like i didn't mean to steal all the time but then like it went two hours and a
half um in poor ac's tame zone i picked a really bad tame zone so she was so tired but she was
having so much fun she didn't want to get off um which was so cute and cute and good which says
cute if you put it dictionary oh we we're gonna possibly do a dictionary there's a new jackbox
18 that's released um okay i was gonna say i'm not sure we can hmm but we had fun on jackbox
it was so mean against ac though because english isn't her first language and one of the game modes
was like asking all these really like hard questions like even english speakers can't get it i felt so
bad for her and she kept like dying in the game i felt so bad um i see no one to get off that's
definitely not true whoa did i say that's in it deep rock galactica has a more players mod
rock and stone hi stroney would you be cool with us making not selling fan articles like
dakis oh you can do unofficial merch as long as you identify as unofficial merch
fucking go wild bro we ain't stepping on your toes and you aren't stepping on ours as long as it's
unofficial merch us all you have to unofficial merch us all you have to do we don't oh we don't
everything's good to go at that point um rock and stone deep rock galactica
wholesome story time with stroney yes that is uh how we all
it had a little icebreaker together it was very kawaii me and i can't say this on youtube but
i inked twice to you today twice over the audio be honest refilling did you lose over the clapping
with your hands audio is that why any plans for roleplays you'd like to do asmr wise for alternative
oh i've got four audios coming out every month on patreon and i'm fine with uh you guys like
submit scripts you want to hear i don't know shame gtfo doesn't support six players i don't even know
what that is wow don't be silly you can't clap without hands can i do it right now i might be
able to do it right now hold on wait let me stand up i might be able to do it right now i don't know
i know i know i know you can laugh hold on i need to hold my midget please
oh wait was that it add my headset on so i never heard it if that if i that did it sorry my heads
it's banging on the mic okay i can like do it all times by default
yeah you doubted it that's ridiculous honestly
okay
nobody can stop her honestly it's such a great clap
well you doubted me i can do it all times i was wrong i'd like to formally apologize i accept
your apology refling and also the other reflings thank you for letting me do that segment just to
prove you wrong oh been a while since i heard that on stream yeah i can do it at any moment i
don't even need like oil or anything i could just do it oh um my suggestions for gen 2 okay i'll hear
you uh refling would like to suggest uh a japanese neon cyber punk hacker girl okay a middle eastern
belly dancer curious a fan to say alchemist girl nature loving flower girl we do love a bit of
nature out here um disciplined ex-military mercenary and a nerdy shy big worm that's quite cute cute
cute suggestion um hi strongy love you did you start v-tubing on your own or were there
that inspired you um inspired i just i saw it and i was like oh fuck it i'll get it go um
and i i'll i've i've told this story before i was very new and i could have easily been rejected
for being an outsider type thing because i do a lot of things that you're not supposed to do
you're not supposed to acknowledge that you're pilot in america but i'm pilot in america and
i acknowledged it uh you're supposed to know the terminology such as zatsu or uh tisker uh well
it's not tisker it's tascaru uh but i call it tisker um and i could have easily have been um eaten
and chewed up and spat out but the community was so loving towards me that um i kept going
basically and i came back and i'm strongy i've always been strongy i've never been any other
vtuber for legal reasons um and yeah now now it's going good it's fantastic um i did like iron mouse
because she's sick as a dog um but like keep streaming anyway uh definitely you can always
kind of lend some energy when you hear stories about like people against all odds like you
you know you got the energy to keep up and keep going type type thing um where's my time in the
robot yeah i keep saying it like tisker like a noise you make when dying what noise that make
when i die uh oh when's my time in the robot oh no i'm a mecca i pilot a mecca like mecca salt
the hit video game from xbox original
um but yeah that my that my mecca story i do a lot of things you're not supposed to do
hey i'm not supposed to say oh i'm recalibrating my tracking uh i'm putting on my my little face
emotes um yeah eh i'm not supposed to do that hold on a minute uh but yeah i do it anyway because
i'm nori get in the robot scrawny get in the mecca oh i'm gonna burp i'm so sorry please open
your mouth okay there we go swallow it good refling okay in regards to hypnosis audios are you gonna
make reinforcement audios for triggers and for audio loops for triggers and affirmations um
you're gonna have to let me start digesting producing it first before i can answer these
kind of questions um i'm staying away from the permanent stuff because it makes me a bit nervous
doing any permanent effects stuff but i already have a public release audio that will undo any
effects i may or may not do on you what did you ask me in particular reinforcement loop for triggers
for triggers um mine's double finger snaps i like it um the most but i will train you in it okay
i am bar i'm embarrassed to admit but i inked to your clapping with no hands and the party role
play oh yeah you like that it was really hot i'm glad you liked it i put a little put a little
bit of my heart into that i like that okay i'll enjoy how it came out um hi strawnee how do you
feel about male figurines being used in bibbute videos yeah you can do that um but maybe maybe
in the future you can use official veiler merch association figurines that's not something i
need a fixation oh i got five at 10 i got seven i got nine at 10 i like the transparency though
because you're just a normal person at the end of the day yeah actually can i say something
that's really disrespectful and i mean no disrespect when i say it you know those vtuber's that have
those donations where like items get thrown at the vtuber model when they get a donation and then the
vtuber goes like the the every time i consume any of that i this is very disrespectful and i don't
mean it this way it makes me cringe to think that they're in a room on their own with the iphone
tracking them and going i'm so sorry i'm like actually so sorry for me for me it's a no but
people find it entertaining which is really cute i like that people can get so entertained and so
enveloped um that it's humorous so i do apologize to anyone that i made him uh i think yeah i've seen
it too twitch integrated throwing system oh okay is that what it's called and yeah and here you are
veiler figures that well adjusted people could be normal don't think about it harder it makes the
cringe yeah i remember seeing a clip about it and i was like don't get me wrong i'm a cringe fest if
you sit through one stream of mine but i remember seeing it and i was like oh that's rough that's
rough even for me to digest but i mean absolutely no disrespect when i say that like whatever
works for you works for you some people are balls to the wall in immersion and that's fantastic
for me um i am absolutely in love that reeflings are in love with pilot in america it makes me
incredibly comfortable um like streaming and acknowledging like oh i need to only go put my
boots on uh instead of like being like i love you so much feeling like bro ain't no one here for that
well some people might be here for that but me i'm not here for that you know um
yeah it's basically just beautiful but i don't mind like the roleplay like if i had a 3d model or
i'll be roleplaying at the wazoo so i'm probably gonna be hypocritical with that statement it's
not even a statement it's just me blabbering any blabberers the heart eyes yeah i love that my
heart eyes are so different like oh my god my squiddles where'd my squiddly pupils go give me my
squiddly pupils back wait wait wait wait hold on you ready for this you ready for this oh wait no
wrong one me when there's no when there's no special honey tea
oh where's my question mark wow
me when me when there's actually a refractory period i can't believe it
any merch you'd like to have made in the future even if it ain't the the typical
merch for me or for the girls um a bash bite uh i'm gonna try and get as a bash bite um i'm not
even pretending otherwise um hi shawnee any plans for age of empire 3 or age of mythology
curious i would have to look at it the current game i'm investigating that i'm not familiar
with right now is baltrol and it looks pretty decent it looks um well well rounded well adjusted
game um and i just need to kind of learn what the heck are flushes and all of that we're brewing
the tea give us a minute honestly weflin's like oh bro give us a minute woman jesus um but yes i'm
currently doing baltrol age of empires i could look into is that that game where you can like
have a king but like a lineage of the region or something i might have seen some gameplay of it
that's what i'm thinking shawnee we love you no matter what mecca you pile oh that's so sweet
thank you see you on my fifth persona in five years time i wonder what i'll look like then
well i'll have double bunches let's let's find out uh any hints for a one-on-one collab and
yeah yesterday um me and mersey hong kong hong kong me and mersey
uh i love you very much and have for a very long time oh let me tell you thank you for
waiting on me it took me a while but sam wise the brave one didn't one time the homies tried
to play age of empires three with me they made an asmr is top oh wait you can make asmr is the
age of empires huh baltrol is my current obsession baltrol is it not called that bala paddle
the spirit is willing but the body is weary and sore not a third persona play no no no i don't
know where i can't be also i can't i'm done in after this i'm strongy and then i'm done um
i'll happily retire many in many years don't stop doing in many years i'll happily retire and i'll
just be like some sort of fucking youtuber runner advisor type thing once all the violator girls
are happy and doing their thing hi strongy your patreon is the most been so good been going back
to them every night and inking yeah you like the vanilla demo a wreath fling you're so cold
but i'm scottish so i can warm you up don't you want to be warmed up
your protonicals getting cold too terrible terrible don't retire no i can't be arse retiring
i've got too many plans i'm sorry but as we say to death not today i have far too many plans to
execute before strongy gets executed i have far too many plans sorry i've put too much love
and soul into strongy and the violator girls that yeah i've got many a year in me i assure you
emi is live in t-minus three minutes okay okay let's bash one out right now
that's terrible i could probably could if i try hard enough um yeah
as someone who's been into bit no kink for a while now i particularly enjoy finger snapping too
yes i do double finger snap to get you under it's my favorite i love double finger snap
your binaural that's the word not your ear binaural finger snap i know you can't hear it
because i'm using a mono microphone right now but i like binaural i'm very much into a fraction
nation fractionation obviously it's the one the practice has been put under and then brought up
and uh thingy oh that would be a that would be a nice challenge that would be a nice challenge
your video of asking to hold it has been weirdly comforting while coding
oh do you like when i completely lose it at the end of the video and i'm just like
poli like absolutely losing it at the end of the video i'm glad it can be a comfort
i might have an official one-k celebration uh ASMR coming out today because i got it halfway
finished edit in but i need to finish edit in the other half and then i need to render it out
and then we'll take it from there because i owe you guys five videos and at the rate
my channel is growing i can't keep up and i have these ASMR collabs with all these lovely girls
per dempah has been waiting on me to record my lines um and i also have a collab with uh
freya and um mimosa the collab list gets pretty long actually there's another
yumi plus grova is a three deal that i need to write our collab with
wow suffering from success yeah you do okay mimosa yeah i was like mimosa's waiting on me
i need to edit our one and he's edit quite a few let her cook yeah she calling you out i know
i know i need to get it edited and slapped up because mimosa actually gave me her png for it
already um so i just need to record my audio put it together um and then put us both in
our lovely little thumbnail and then i'll add mimosa in the title and then you guys can discover
mimosa um she's been nothing but a delight and she completely i am like 100 completely comfortable
with mimosa and i've only known her for a week um like she's just been so polite and kind and
tells me tells me all the things i love it when someone information shares with me i love getting
new knowledge oh really yeah oh i'm not uncomfortable around you and winky winky baby oh my god you're
so cheeky mimosa i'm so cheeky oh my god emmy's getting her dogs out okay right speaking of letting
the dogs out i am going to read that was diva yes um i am going to redirect into none other than
emmy bezu to celebrate her monetization stream yes please enjoy emmy and her dogs i wonder how
different her dogs look compared to my dogs um but it's been fantastic please enjoy all 10 of
her toenails while you're at it pay extra attention uh what redirect yes a redirect or read is the
terminology used i had an absolute fantastic time on crash bandicoot with you i cannot recommend
playing warped um in your own time it was magnificent 10 out of 10 game highly recommend
please do enjoy emmy to her to your full extent um and hopefully you'll see some cheeky channel
updates possibly an ac asmr a mersey asmr an astronzo asmr because i owe you so much asmr
but thank you so so much reeflings today was absolutely fantastic you have put a smile on
my face and i i love you very much for it and tomorrow we're gonna play buckshot roulette and
i will reveal to you what my evil dastardly plans are for next week of streams okay so i'll see you
tomorrow look after emmy for you and i give you one big kiss one big kiss right one big
wet slovery okay maybe two wet slovery kisses see you tomorrow reeflings okay bye oh my voice
just cracked did you hear that i'm embarrassed i'm embarrassing okay okay okay okay bye see you
tomorrow reeflings bye bye bye